Hey everybody,
the fuck is going on.
Joe Diaz.
What are you doing over there?
What's happening,
baby baby?
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by [inaudible] dot com it's
o,
n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain shroom,
tech sport.
True Tech Immune.
I say this the same way every day.
Now there's really no way around that.
You fucked it.
Makes it up just a bit.
I can try it guys.
Go to on it.
Dot Code and and search around.
Yeah.
You use a code name.
Rogan.
Give yourself some fucking Alpha brain.
I didn't take mine yet.
I got to tell you over here.
What did you like?
Remember to take years if you're on alphabet.
No,
no.
If your kids,
oh,
that's true.
Constantly distracted.
It's,
you know,
you're,
you're happy.
It's great,
but constantly distract your place is very like playful.
Like,
like the whole atmosphere of your house has become what used to be devil's
asshole to fucking Alice in wonderland.
It's amazing.
Devil's asshole.
That's funny.
Well,
I used to want to live by myself.
I had a all like crazy Asian art in my house.
Looks like most of my house was like
had Peralta's for awhile.
I'll fucking
shit.
Fucking pit bulls fighting on the 4th of July.
[inaudible] stick a finger in his ass,
blood off the shirt and all of a sudden now you walk in,
it's fucking Disney land.
I know.
I loved it every way you're bumping it to cause they like want to make a cabbie.
They're beautiful.
Positive energy now used to be like real
rape me now.
Well Listen,
Ladies and gentlemen,
I'm never,
never claimed to be a balanced person.
The first time I went to the other house I go,
can I get somebody to free?
Had nothing that was old cold cuts and the bottom that had been open?
Nothing.
Well,
when you live by yourself,
what the fuck was this is when you didn't even think of a woman.
Nothing.
You live like Charles Bronson and hard times you had,
you had a house that you only use run,
walk,
run room and a pool table.
Everything else is wide open,
you know?
And it was fucking just a blend of protein powder.
You're hungry.
I order food.
I'm hungry mixing,
you know,
eight pizzas are showing up.
One time he came at it from the smuggler wiggly [inaudible].
There was so much food,
Bro.
It was four of us.
He fucking catered this thing.
He's like eat guys.
They was trays of food.
It's so good.
So good.
If you never been the Hughley walking these Brian.
Yeah,
I've been to Figley wigglies you've been there with me.
No.
Hughley walkies with you.
No,
I went to,
actually I'm talking about Piggly Wigglys Hughley Walkleys the the barbecue
place in Van I
easiest fucking,
well,
I went with Phil Hartman.
I went to,
yeah,
Phil Hartman.
Man.
The way he would look at Pussy,
it was like,
he was looking at a beautiful flower,
like a girl had a beautiful flower that she was showing them and very child like
as if a young girl had a beautiful flower.
Like it wasn't even dirty.
He,
the girl was like,
she had her asshole and his face and he had his big smile on his face.
He was high as fuck.
And I'll never forget that.
He's like,
that's beautiful.
Whose Dad is beautiful?
And it was just so earnest and so like appreciative and I swear it wasn't even
remotely creepy.
It was nice.
He was looking at this dirty stripper and he was so high and so in tune.
Then he was just being really nice to her about it.
Who's really happy,
like that's beautiful.
That's beautiful.
Like he wasn't creepy at all.
He was like,
if you were a woman in a strip club and you met him in that situation you would,
you would have a good,
that was an enjoyable conversation for her.
There wasn't anything creepy or dirty about it.
You would want to go out and buy some battle ropes after watching this and
getting,
trying to do this commercial.
No commercial
commercial is always work like that.
This whole,
that whole,
the whole last five art yesterday,
our commercial was 17 minutes.
That's part of the show.
This is part of the show.
You can still get this,
get it on iTunes know it's so nice to have it on Sirius [inaudible].
Most of it's on Sirius.
This part ain't,
this ain't bitch.
You see you iTunes people,
you use stream people.
This is all you want to say who I was listening to because I,
I found it.
Dot.
Tom.
We coordinate road rugged.
I don't want to say who I was listening to,
what I was,
I found out my new car has Sirius radio and so I been listening to this one
person.
I don't get opie and Anthony,
so I've been listening to this other channel and I'm sitting there going,
you know what?
What we produce is so much more entertaining I think,
and like our friends like Ari shift fear and Thompson what they produced.
Say it.
No Way,
no way.
So Okay Duncan even,
but all the things that we produce are so much more entertaining then fucking I
just taught us to us.
I don't know man.
I can't very specific.
It's really interesting to me what's going on with some of these radio shows is
because it's just the same shit every fucking day and they're just,
it's like a soap opera of people screaming.
Let's get through this commercial.
Kind of a good thing to talk about because it's been very,
and know exactly what you're saying,
whatever.
Go to on.com and check out some shit.
What is a,
what are Alpha brain?
What does Alpha brands in nootropic and when nootropics,
ours is a very controversial field of vitamins and nutrients,
being able to enhance brain function.
There is some evidence,
there's a a very detailed website on on a.com where it goes over all of the
different scientific aspects of each individual ingredient.
It's like I said,
it is,
it is a controversial thing.
It's gets a lot of people up
in arms,
but I,
I firmly believe in nutrition and I firmly believe in supplementing nutrition
and I know it's aided me and I know Alpha brain most certainly aids me.
I,
I absolutely enjoy the effects.
It's not a placebo by any stretch of the imagination and to make sure that
people don't think it is the way we have it set up as if you,
you order 30 pills,
you get a hundred percent money back guarantee,
you don't even have to return the product.
You just say,
it sucked.
Give me my money back,
it's over.
And we just don't want anybody to feel ripped off.
So that's how we have it set up.
Um,
we also have,
uh,
Justin,
battle ropes and kettlebells.
We're starting to sell fitness equipment.
All the shit that I use,
all the shit that is like really,
uh,
the kind of stuff that you see like MMA fighters use is trying to conditioning
videos w body weight,
like full body exercise movements like clean and press and,
and Hindu squats and chin ups and things where you move your body around plus
weight,
you know,
you these Turkish getups.
These things are amazing for your core strength.
It's just wood.
Kettlebells are is basically,
it's like a cannon ball with a handle on it and one of the coolest exercises as
you just lying down on your back and standing up with that thing and then
bringing your brown down to your back and then standing up with it again.
It is fucking hard.
Try doing that shit with a 70 pound kettle bells fuck man.
To balance that bitch out,
straighten your arm out and you engage muscles in a way that you almost never do
by traditional weightlifting.
It's really a weird type of working out and I enjoy it and it's my favorite
strength and conditioning exercises as far as like applicable strength for
Jujitsu and um,
for uh,
I think for anything athletic,
anything we'd have to move things around.
When you have a body that's used to moving it around itself around plus weight
in really awkward ways,
you develop a very strong body and there's a lot of videos online.
We have summit on at.com we're going to produce some videos and uh,
take you guys through a really good strength and conditioning work on.
I think that would be a great thing for us to do too.
Just so you can get a sense of like what kind of benefits you can get from,
especially if you see some of these like really fit dudes that are,
you know,
like these like Steve Maxwell type dudes that have been doing it their whole
lives that are in there.
Yeah.
Maxwell,
I think it's like close to 60 and he looks fucking phenomenal and he's a big
advocate of a,
of kettle bells and battle ropes with these.
Ours might have seen him.
Brock Lesnar use them and one of the countdown shows that these giant ropes and
electric you would like tie a ship down with like 40 feet long and they have
these uh,
kept ends and you grab a hold of him and you whip these motherfuckers through
the air and you can do these different sequences of movements like in sprint you
doing for like sprints of 30 seconds and then you relax for 20 seconds and then
sprint for 30 seconds and holy fuck is it brutal?
I mean it is some old school caveman type shit,
throwing ropes around man.
And when you throw ropes around,
it's a,
it's a real wild thing,
man.
It's like all your,
everything's working kind of together,
but it's,
it's all like one big unit.
You know,
your,
your whole body whipping these ropes and on balanced in shit and you're
correcting for him all the time and moving him and whipping them left and
whipping them riding.
It's fucking wild,
man.
It's a burns you out quick.
Like,
you would think I could probably do that for half an hour.
The fuck you can.
They'll fuck you can 30 seconds into doing that shit.
You want to die.
It's amazing.
It's a great workout.
Um,
so,
uh,
go check all that shit out.
Use a code name Brogan,
and you get 10% off of any of the supplements.
And I'm including hemp force was just gets released today.
The most fucking delicious hemp protein you've ever tasted in your life.
There's the top level shit.
It's all natural and it's even naturally sweetened.
It's sweetened with Stevia,
raw cocoa and super nutritious.
This stuff is phenomenal for you and uh,
it's fucking expensive.
I'm going to be honest with you.
Um,
it's,
it's expensive to make.
It's expensive to get the good,
but it's the shit.
Well,
it's because the hemp,
the hemp farms is only like three farms in Canada then it's be because our
country is fucking retarded when it comes to certain plants.
Hamp is illegal.
Even though hemp is not psychoactive,
you can't get high from it.
Hemp is illegal.
Well,
hemp is a tremendous source of protein.
And even though we're allowed to buy him products in this country,
like hemp protein,
which we import from Canada,
even though you're allowed to buy it,
you can't grow it here.
So it's,
it's really stupid.
It's the farms have limited production.
They can't keep up with the demand.
We and we can't do anything about it.
It's not,
it would just pay some American farmers to start growing hemp here and put
people,
put American workers,
you know,
uh,
to work.
And that's like a Mitt Romney type thing.
You know,
we need hemp farms.
You,
you're fucking twats.
Anyway,
go get some help for us.
It's fucking delicious.
It is a really the best tasting hemp protein shit I've ever had.
It's a hamp with this Stevia to it and it's,
it's really delicious.
You the code name Rogan and you can save 10% off and it's not as bad,
but it ain't cheap.
But that's life pitches.
It's expensive.
Shit is expensive.
Joey Diaz is here and heightened a fuck.
Strap it down.
Joey's here.
Let's get the party started.
Experience Joe Rogan podcast by night.
He bull behave.
People behave mad flavors.
Here.
What baby growing up my brother,
I can't call it getting ready for that,
but it's weekend.
Damn my mother fucking idiot.
You're in a,
yeah.
If you're in Cincinnati,
go check out my man Duncan Trussell Dunkin trust is going to be a go in
Cincinnati
all weekend.
Have you never done go bananas?
I places great places.
It's pretty.
That's great.
I did have a place back in the nineties man.
I only did it once,
but I enjoyed it.
It's a real old school comedy club.
I pleased it.
Shit.
Denver paramount theater this weekend.
Friday night,
mother fucking 50 this this Friday.
The best show is going to be Joey Diaz,
Joe Rogan and Brendan Walsh.
That's what we just said.
[inaudible] no,
I was just [inaudible] reinstate.
Reinforcing though.
You're you.
Are you talking shit about Dunkin again?
God dammit.
Let it go son.
What you doing by saying that's the best show to go see,
not to go see the one in Cincinnati.
No,
it was just reinforcing that your guys a show in my opinion,
is the best show in the fucking road.
I love all three of those comics and putting them together.
I love Britain walls.
I think he's hilarious.
He is like,
we just did the bone zone last night and that is a fun thing for me to do.
Like it's fun doing the bone zone.
That's how awesome.
I think last night with you guys.
Oh it's,
we just do it.
We don't ever have guessed really?
Which she wouldn't have been somebody else.
Randy Lik can Davey Johnson.
Yeah.
They're very funny guys.
They're very smart guys.
So of of a cool sense of humor.
You know Brendan is a very funny standup too.
Very funny.
I'm looking forward to this.
We're going to have a good fucking time block.
Yeah.
I can't wait to eat.
I love that stuff.
I love guns.
All that stuff.
Does it feel weird to you go in there right after the tragedy.
I haven't gone to see the movie yet because I don't want to sit down.
I want to sit there and go,
this is what these pull last people seen as what?
They got scared.
I didn't even think of that,
that angle of it.
I never thought about it like that,
but I just,
the tragedy,
it was a bad thing.
It was four weeks.
So can you imagine something like that hitting close to home when you start
seeing people that are trying to do a copycat crimes now,
didn't you say that someone got arrested in Ohio,
in Ohio,
somebody came up with like a knife,
a gun,
ammo,
everything.
You know,
you know,
this is where the real cynical people,
the really cynical,
crazy conspiracy people,
these are the ones,
this is where they start thinking that the government is doing this and that
they're doing this on purpose because they want to disarm Americans because they
know that everything's going to fall apart and they don't want people to have
guns.
I mean,
that's sounds completely ridiculous,
but if you were going to write a movie about how some super corrupt
multinational corporations figure out a way to control the whole world,
it would probably write it like that.
You'd probably,
you'd probably have everything wired and hooked up like that.
Right?
If you throw the Jab,
Alex Jones,
I am his witness and Houston at the UFC.
He told me to my face,
I did two years,
there was only be TSA security at Parks and movie theaters and I was right there
when he told me that.
He told me that to my face was sitting outside of the UFC and we're just talking
about different things.
So
what is it?
Is it because,
is it just a natural thing
that you know,
because there's a lot of crime because there's a lot of disparate.
The economy's in the toilet,
it's just,
it's a natural thing that things pop off and crazy people do shit like this.
Or do you want to follow the conspiracy theory point where they think that
they're doing this on purpose because they've engineered the collapse of the
dollar.
They know that the world economy is going to implode and they don't want people
to be armed.
They want to be able to maintain power.
I wasn't looking at it like that.
I'm a very cynical person.
I was looking at it as a business angle.
You know what,
fucking shoot somebody to move movie theater.
They got to put security of 2 million thousand movie theaters across the
country.
The next is parks,
whatever.
But that I come to my senses,
I wake up and I put the joint down and then I go to bad things happen every
fucking day.
But you know,
that's here.
They happen,
they happen somewhere.
That is though,
if you were a government and you are evil and you were trying to control the
people,
that is what you do.
You,
you organize attacks.
And it's been pointed out before that the American public has tried to do this
or the mare,
excuse me,
the American,
the government has tried to do this.
They at one point in time to the,
um,
operation Northwoods was written,
where was an idea that they were gonna do,
were gonna fake attacks on American civilians to get us to go to war with Cuba.
They're going to blow up a jet liner and say there was people in it there we're
going to arm Cuban friendlies to tack wan taught them,
obey.
It was going to be,
but that's,
that's like a real thing that they were going to do to try to get us into a war
with Cuba.
So when you find out about conspiracies like crazy things like that where you're
like,
wow,
like they would fake shit.
Like they're allowed to think like that when that came out.
That should have been a huge piece of news.
That should have been something where you know,
everyone demanded that should be hearings on this.
It should be like brought out in front of the public.
People should be in the streets like screaming about this.
Like how is this possible?
How would they now prosecuted?
They were really going to risk American lives and have Americans killed just to
further their agenda.
They were going to fake an act of war in order to get us into war because they
thought they knew better than us.
So it was this just one dumb fuck that just like,
hey this is my idea.
And they're like,
all right,
come on.
Stop.
What was signed by the Joint Chiefs of Staff is the joints chiefs of stats on,
did they have a math problem at the time and they got like new ones like the
next day.
I think they used to rocket like that all the time.
That's why when you know you,
these conspiracy nuts come out and they say,
hey,
we believe that this guy was brainwashed and someone got ahold of him and they
did an experiment with him and he's like a Manchurian candidate.
It sounds fucking completely ridiculous.
It sounds completely ridiculous.
But if,
uh,
if they were willing to do that other stuff,
why wouldn't they be willing to do that if they really could do that?
You imagine if they figured out a way to reprogram people,
if it wasn't science fiction,
you don't think they would do it.
Of course they would do it.
If the government really did find some super sophisticated way where they could
just say pumpkin to you and you fucking snap and,
and why yourself up
with grenades and run into a room full of important people and blow yourself up,
you don't think they would do that?
Of course they would.
That's a great way to do it.
You get some idiot is willing to do that for you and have him walk in and pull
the trigger.
It's amazing.
I haven't really focused on the Colorado thing as much cause he's just fucking
negative and anything like that until my mind,
my mind is just tragic,
right?
I want to know what the fuck happened.
I want to know where the system went wrong.
Now you've heard I'd been here before and I told you about Colorado.
We both discuss Colorado,
but I've lived in New York,
California,
and I hang out with gangsters and the craziest motherfuckers.
I know when the amounts.
Yeah,
I'm okay now let's just leave that.
You know I've been reading bits and pieces like he was going to a
psychotherapist or psychiatrist.
I don't know.
Now she alarmed somebody.
She warned somebody.
Just psycho therapists.
This is what I heard.
Is this true or is this not true?
Who did she want?
Who does she want him?
Why weren't these people?
Why was this fucking lunatic contact?
Then the other side of me says,
I understand we can't react to every fucking call the police because a guy up
here waving a gun,
is he hurt anybody?
No,
we cannot respond to every call because of the budgets and whatever.
So who dropped this?
This is a kid that bought thousands of rounds of ammunition at a local fucking
place.
The guns all legit.
Like I told you in Colorado,
but you can buy a fucking bazooka.
What was your pay?
And he'll,
Brian does your dog and cat shit.
Get her out of there.
She's in my fucking cat's litter box.
Get her,
get her.
Get her.
Jesus Christ.
This is what fucks with me a lot.
Shut that door,
man.
This is what?
Fuck,
sorry folks.
Sorry folks.
This is a real shot.
This is how it works.
This is what fucks with me.
How the system fail that this big got fucking helmets
we had at the fucking system fail.
It fails somewhere and where did he get the money?
They said that the speculation was that he used as a scholarship money.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
I didn't know you could just use your scholarship money for other shit and you
thought you had to pay for school.
He withdrew.
Well when you get a scholarship,
but you're like responsible for that money,
like say if you've got $20,000 for a scholarship,
did you,
uh,
do you actually have to spend that money on the college or could you like,
and like Gerber baby an insurance that I got for myself when I was 17,
I bought a baby Gerber insurance now,
but I guess like the Gerber Insurance,
like uh,
I don't know what you did.
You just do apply for a college essay.
She'll get a grant.
You get a grant,
you got to find that financial aid.
You got to pay back.
They'll give it to you once.
You got one fucking long going to give me what the fuck you want.
You'll keep giving it to you.
A plus La,
I forget all the pell grant.
You don't have to pay back.
That's a grant,
but all those loans you got to pay back.
I'm gonna tell you something.
You sign up for college.
Let's say your parents are not that well off.
You sign up for college,
they cover the tuition and you reach out and you could get all these grants
available to you.
There's a lot of fucking money out there available to you for what he was going
to school for.
You know?
Especially
for what he was going to school for it.
This kid was a genius wasn't it psycho fucking something alleyway that I don't
know what the fuck it was called.
They give you the loop.
They continuously are you going to spend on the back?
They give you the loop bro.
I was taking college money when I was going to university of Colorado and buying
cars with the curbing him like seeing like a Volkswagen for 800 and sell for 400
for 1200 that's what I was doing with my financial aid money.
What you do is you sign up rating and credits and you get money for 18 credits
but right before the school season starts you cut it down to nine and you pocket
that gayness.
By the time they know what the fuck is going on and they sent you a letter in
the mail.
The gators is gone.
It's of the happy.
I'll go deal with the bartender and the coke dealer.
That might be the greatest word ever.
Gators gave us divis,
Dina's,
Guida S.
See,
I always thought it was gators,
Doug Gee,
this is,
if you live in Florida,
you hate alligators.
This is this cock sucking.
But you know,
I've heard people call a gator's though.
Not that's
Peter's is shit.
But that was,
uh,
my friend Johnny used that term.
Get us,
we talked when he's talking about gambling money,
my guess
kind of get that gayness.
I feel
bad for what happened in Colorado.
It was a fucked up said,
but I want to know where he got.
I want to know how he learned to light the fucking smokescreen.
Well,
he was a genius.
He could have figured that online.
Do they teach you this shit online?
I'm scared to even fucking look at by a,
you could figure out the plans to build a nuclear bomb online.
Like you literally,
yeah,
sure.
I'm,
I'm pretty positive.
Yeah,
I bet.
If you were smart enough,
you're smart enough and you had access to him for what's in there.
A kid who was trying to build a nuclear bomb in his backyard,
there's a million right now that are trying to do that.
But no,
there was a kid who got arrested.
Yeah,
but he's building a nuclear bomb in his backyard is it sounds like horse shit.
I kind of hold on a nuclear bomb.
Oh,
I see.
So you can learn all this shit online.
I don't know why some of these,
I mean that thing he did at home,
what he wired his house with bombs and fucking liquids and all that Shit.
He learned that outline.
What you guys are fucking trying to tell me.
Yeah.
This kid and this kid was a some dangerous nut man.
He tried to build a nuclear bomb and his mom's shed.
There was a kid who really did it.
Was He tried,
he did he think he was trying like it.
Was he using like real materials or was he using like cheers they see,
no,
he was using real materials.
That's how they got them.
Apparently they ha they keep a very close eye on all of the Pie Tonio of the
world.
You know,
it's very hard to get Tony and we know whatever it is,
whether it's plutonium or whatever it is they use to,
they need to make some sort of a nuclear weapon.
We know what that stuff is supposedly and then we keep an eye on it.
But to be Jesus Christ,
Marty McFly can get it.
Anyone can get it.
If this fucking kid can make this shit in his yard,
you know,
I mean,
what is he that much smarter?
Everybody else
does shit that fuck my world up was one of the night I was watching discovery
and they showed you how to make speed on fucking this guy.
They had these kids,
they showed you how to make steroids speed and something else.
It's steroids guys live right here in Sherman oaks or something that had like a,
you know,
like outlaw things on their faces and they show how they cook them on the stove
and stuff.
And this,
this is a crazy asshole.
They pulled him over and this is the guy's name.
His name is David Hahn.
He was 17 years old.
Uh,
the,
the police pulled him over and they found radioactive materials and the trunk of
his car,
his mother's property was cleared up on the environmental protection agency 10
months later as a super fund cleanup site.
This mother fucker like really did,
I mean he was like,
he came really close.
Wow.
Okay.
He made his own nuclear reactor.
Holy Shit.
He attained his eagle scout rank in the boy scouts shortly after.
It was what's his name was dismantled.
They,
the boy scouts still let them have an eagle scout.
I let them run the fucking party.
He's not getting fucking the scout troop.
Benevolent leader.
His name was David Hawn.
It says while his reactor never reached critical mass,
Han attracted the attention of local police are found radioactive materials.
Huh?
Be careful what that chocolate bar just so I guess he came really close to just
eat that whole chocolate bar.
I just want to let you know there's a gentleman that's,
I'm just a regular chocolate bark.
Joey Diaz just participated in.
I know that's the one that you said it was the highest you've ever done a
podcast and what's at whammy bar from La speedway?
It didn't,
there's just no,
I didn't need to be talking.
There's no need for me to be talking about
when you're that baked.
Oh please.
I just not the debt.
We want you to talk to watch it.
We don't want you to go into
essentials.
We don't want you to go into the chocolate whole great fighters tickets.
Right.
That's losing fights in a long,
long time and I think I was thinking about it.
I think they should do just as many la fights as they do Vegas because it's
really the same shit.
The same people kind of Miss Golf,
you know?
I mean,
and it was fun.
It was positive.
The fights were fucking great.
Joel Lowe's on Jesus Christ.
If I could come back and recycled myself,
I come back as Joe Lowe's serious.
I love that Jujitsu Shit like that.
He's a fuck.
I love.
Everything he did was awesome and Jamie Varner was awesome.
Man.
That guy's making a huge comeback.
He just didn't have enough time to get into condition for this fight.
I think eight weeks,
four weeks.
I think he took it on short notice.
So you know,
it's a tough fight.
Joe Lozan is uh,
it's one of the best.
He's a dangerous kid.
He's got a lot of tools.
One thing I love about Joe Lowe's on is when they match them up just by Uli,
like if they match up against somebody who's a great striker,
does striker,
I know Joe loads and that hasn't been a chance of winning.
This is the craziest drilling because if you hit you,
gets on his
back,
he attack you from his back.
He don't give a fuck.
He said he fucked up a couple of people.
Let me get a,
and Gallard too.
Yeah.
He got up and go.
I can do that.
Jumping and screaming.
He fucking did keep,
Melvin keeps talking like saying that Joe Lowe's on got lucky.
But let me tell you something.
When someone wants to punch you in the face and they do punch you in the face,
that's not luck.
Okay.
That's what he wanted to do and that's what he did.
It ain't no lucky punches.
Did you just say it's a lucky punch is one of the craziest things people could
ever say when you rush in like that like he did with his face exposed with a
good fighter,
a guy is going to snap off a jam on you.
I think you probably underestimated Lozan striking,
you know,
his striking Melvin's striking so good and so fast.
He's so fast,
man.
When you watch him put combinations together and go,
God damn it's technique just clean.
He's got a lot of power in his hands and I think he just got a little
overconfident in Lozan is not to be fucked with like 44 fights or something.
Those on is obese.
Dude,
that was an awesome fight.
He's smart.
That's the most dangerous thing about Joe Lowe's on is he's smart.
You know?
And then I'm looking for Anthony.
Anthony Pettis just knocked Joe Lowe's on the out in the first round,
their fight,
you know,
and he hasn't fought since then.
I'm looking forward to seeing him fight again.
I think you've got an injured though.
Pedes.
Yeah,
it's,
they're trying to set something up with him at cowboy Cerrone of Serone gets by
Gallard.
Even if he doesn't your bike go out and still be a great fine,
and my man got her caught check us out or it gets Ellenberger he's got a disc
bulging disc.
But dog this week,
God,
people always like,
why are these fighters getting injured?
Well,
they're in the business of their,
their business is getting really good at fucking people up.
That's what they're doing.
So in the only way to get really good at fucking be blocked because you got to
practice fucking people up all day and while you're practicing fucking people
up,
people get fucked up.
Did you fuck you?
How happy were you?
I mean,
it's an impartial.
I was happy as fuck and I gave him a lot of respect.
Mike's wick.
Oh my God,
we gotta respect seven one mother bucket three bitches.
And I'll tell you what before that,
demarcus look fantastic.
Yeah,
you just caught,
caught him.
Perfect man.
When he caught that leg and drop that right hand on it,
man,
it was perfect placement.
He did it so fast.
Like demarcus just,
just,
he just went out with that first shot and then switched,
tagged him two more times for the ref.
Got to him like a fucking karate kid.
And Beta was a great fight.
Dude.
Liotta Machida is scary guy.
You gotta you gotta get,
you gotta get ahold of that guy and it's,
that's no picnic either.
He just got great wrestling and great use of his body.
He did a lot of sumo when he was a kid,
which sounds silly,
right?
So,
but they,
they really,
they're really good at like throwing people off in certain directions and
pushing forward and,
and planting yourself.
And,
you know,
he's,
he's got amazing tricks that he does inside with like little leg trips and shit
like that.
It'd be interesting to see,
uh,
him,
versus look if he,
if Henderson somehow or another beats Jon Jones seeing him the Oda Machida
versus Henderson,
I would really like to see that fight.
That would be crazy.
I would love to that fight because they're both kind of on the small side for
light heavyweight,
the Oda way to oh one Henderson's usually somewhere around there.
Even when he fights it,
two oh five,
he usually weighs around 200 ish.
You know,
I think that would be an incredible fight.
Henderson Jones is going to be a crazy fight to man if Henderson wins.
He's like the greatest mixed martial arts fighter of all time.
If you really look at it,
if you look at it like as far as accomplishments,
they've got wins.
Two different titles in pride in two different weight classes at,
and then he holds them at the same time.
It comes over to strike force.
When's the title and strike for us?
He has,
he's a knockout over heavyweights.
Like fate or million.
ENCO got knocked out fatal.
You know what I mean?
Dan Henderson is a mother fucker dude.
That guy is a motherfucker.
You can never sleep on that.
Let's see if he figures out Jon Jones,
if he fit the fingers on anybody.
Man,
he's got that.
He's got that one weapon that's so retarded.
Strong.
His right hand is so powerful and he has this crazy confidence in it and he can
takes it.
He takes an amazing shot.
He's so tough.
So he'll wade through some shit to get to you and clip you with that thing and
just put the lights out.
Man.
He's dangerous man.
He's fucking dangerous.
And I think he's more dangerous at two oh five and he hasn't won 85.
I think especially as you get older,
it's hard for a guy like that to cuddle that weight.
You know?
I think when he doesn't cut weight and he's one of the rare guys that can do it.
If fights effectively at two oh five.
And I think when he doesn't cut that way,
I think maybe,
uh,
maybe he feels a little bit healthier at a so many a years of doing that shit.
Man.
That's like one of the worst aspects of fighting.
It's the weight cutting.
Sad drives me nuts because it's,
the sport is always supposed to be about being healthy.
It's supposed to be about,
you know,
like you know your body being tuned in in the best possible way for combat,
but it's really not because of the 24 hours before you fight,
you fuck it up hard core,
you suck all the water out of it so you could flight in a lower weight class.
It's this weird fucking silly thing that's still around.
It shouldn't,
it shouldn't be a factor.
It should be.
It really,
honestly,
it is a part of the sport is probably no getting rid of it at this point without
some sort of a radical restructuring of the way people look at martial arts.
But I think that it's almost like it's,
it's not in the proper spirit of martial arts and competition.
I feel like,
I feel like you have to do it today if you're a professional because everyone's
doing it and if you want to fight against guys your size,
there's only one way to do that.
You're going to have to fight against.
You know,
you're going to have to fight against the scales.
Well,
you're going to have to cut weight and you're going to have to go in because
everybody else is doing it.
Otherwise you're not going to win.
You're not going to beat 190 pound guy if you really wait one 70 if he's just as
skilled as you,
you know,
that extra 20 pounds,
even though it fucked his organs up and might have almost shut it's kidney down
and he had to get reinflated with Ivs.
He's probably still gonna beat you
because he's a bigger guy and he's got more mass,
especially if you can get you to the ground and have more space,
more strength of,
more,
more to push around.
And when they refuel themselves with ivy and he's like,
they can do it pretty well with Ivs,
we're in 24 hours,
you know,
it's worth it for them,
but it's still bad for your body.
And it's unfortunate and I think I,
I hate the idea that those people have to do that,
you know,
sucks.
What are you going to do?
It's part of the fucking game.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
We've got to go to a Starbucks and write jokes.
They got to lose fucking white.
I know,
but wouldn't it be better if they all just fought their way class,
I think,
which I think a perfect utopia of mixed martial arts would be everybody fights
in one of the fuck their way and we find out what everybody waves.
We just naturally you get this is what you weigh when you're in shape.
What do you,
what do you weigh when you're like,
uh,
like when dog fighting shape,
when they used to fight dogs,
you know that he used to weigh him in.
Do you know that shit now?
Yeah.
The,
the really light ones.
Just the ones they want.
You don't like see these big giant pit bulls that everybody has today.
These people have bred these things to make them really big and crazy.
But I had a friend who had like one of the really small game once.
It was crazy,
a little animal man.
It was a really smart,
they don't even have to look like if they're really small.
It was like 35 pounds.
Are you serious?
No,
barely have.
Basically you can get a 20 pounds,
25 pound pit bull.
There's a really small ones,
but those little,
little tiny ones are crazy.
They don't look like pit bulls.
Like where would,
we're used to seeing them with like the really boxy,
muscular heads and huge shoulders.
Like those are the pitfalls you see on the streets.
The amazing looking dogs,
the ones that you use an angel heart to bite Mickey Rourke,
the two little fucking pit bulls and New Orleans watch that movie with a little
real little ones.
We'll look at them and go,
oh,
that's weird.
It was 87 so nobody really knew about the fucking pit bull who was still stuck
on Goldman pinches retrievers some.
Yeah,
some people know about and they made that movie when they sent the mob guy to
beat him up in that movie,
the devil,
whether it beats him up in Angel Heart,
that's what he had.
These little tiny pimples that we didn't even have a big chest when they fucking
ran after him.
You could even see they ran different,
like it was the beginning before they started giving him juice and gun powder.
Do you know at one point in time the pit bull was like a,
the the,
they were trying to argue for it being the national animal.
Like instead of the ego representation of America was going to be a pit bull.
Pretty lucky.
Yeah.
There was a,
there was a movement for that.
I got that movement like three guys and Compton.
It was pretty legit.
Man.
I
wish her neck remember this.
Totally.
But I haven't had pit bulls in the year and so I've forgotten all the
propaganda.
Um,
uh,
American animal,
by the way.
Tonight we have an amazing show at the ice house.
There's still some tickets left.
Yeah.
How many are left?
I think there's like 40.
Okay.
It's,
if you've ever been there,
the ice houses one of the best clubs in the world,
isn't it?
Joey was,
how great is
that fucking place?
I don't give a fuck if they did this show in a barn.
You fucking Moses,
Dom Irrera,
Tom Road,
Joe Rogan,
Doug Benson,
and fucking red man.
Same Shit and cancel.
What the fuck you don't tell your grandmother some indic call (626) 577-1836 and
get those tickets.
Now I'm talking about Tom Road.
Joe Rogan,
a fucking IRA and dug beds.
Bert Kreischer,
just those four.
It's like 50 and a blowjob to fucking get the pocket.
So get your shit together.
You're fucking most showing the ice house.
That shouldn't be sold.
I'm in Orange County,
but it ain't going to fucking get back on.
And then I will get back to about 1130 12 I'm going to a sandwich place to land
in Orange County named Roscoe's to fucking excited about a sandwich.
No,
no,
I'm not.
I'm not excited about it.
As much as they do comedy at this sandwich place now and they serve beer.
They had beer and wine,
no booze,
but it's fucking sandwiches,
like old school sandwiches and you go down and you'd do fucking 30 minutes.
They give you a little doll pumper nickles and they get the fuck out of it.
You know what I'm saying?
That's it.
But I like to think got like 90 a hundred people and it's really fucking cool.
But on the way back,
I'll stop up there.
I'll try to shoot the one on one too.
Fucking hot.
That's what it is,
dog.
This is brutal.
If I got one on a plane Friday cup,
it's going to be a hundred motherfucking 10 on Friday.
It was 13 or 13 or something like that.
Just on my way here mean listen,
they said that this July was the hottest July ever in the country.
The whole country ever.
Okay.
That's all the untrue ever.
I know they did.
They talked about it in La.
I tweeted it today.
I retweeted it cause it was ridiculous.
It's pretty bad when I have to leave my air conditioning on full blast at home
just so my cats don't die.
Yeah,
yeah,
you do,
right?
Yeah,
you're there.
It's hard.
It's fuck around on the floor.
They haven't fucking mood.
No beds,
no nothing there on the floor getting that fucking cool.
Would I last night in my bedroom I couldn't get it freezing.
It's usually freezing cold but it wasn't freezing last night.
It was cold enough for me to fall asleep,
but I got up to pee like at four of them.
Like what the fuck is this?
Usually I got the blanket on her.
That's weird.
Fucking they glue.
But last night was,
it's tough.
It's been a hot fucking weekend.
And you didn't feel the earthquake last night I was at flappers and then on the
one I was driving home I seen all the cop cars and then when I came in people
were on Facebook.
There was an earthquake.
I don't feel that shit.
A lot of people called me a pussy because I felt that I wasn't at the Ice House
and it was like a huge jolt and then like a sway in the whole building made like
this crackly noise and I'm like okay,
I'm getting the fuck out of here because this building is way like building some
check,
check to,
you know,
it's not,
if you look they have those things already in the walls or retrofits.
We have 50 it's like the outside of it.
It's just retrofit,
retrofit,
retrofit.
Retrofit.
So I'm thinking if I'm gonna,
if there's ever an earthquake here,
run the fuck out of this building.
Might collapse.
Yeah.
It might collapse billings
bricks.
That's why it's not that the bricks are going to fall apart,
but they shift or that shift because you hear that shit.
Yeah,
that is traumatizing.
And so it looked at Hollywood.
I live in a brick building kind of.
Couple of people were calling me pussies and stuff like on Twitter.
Me Like you're a pussy,
pussy,
you know?
And I'm like,
all right,
you could be in Malibu,
which is a lot farther away from where I was at,
you know,
to the earthquake and be like,
oh yeah,
I didn't feel anything you pussy,
you know?
But that would,
I felt last night was fucking jolting.
That was like,
oh,
I didn't feel,
I forgot there's earth.
This is earthquake stuff just underneath me.
Yes.
Yeah.
It gets so hot.
I am only hoping that since nobody ever predicts things correctly that because
you're saying it's earthquake,
whatever that you're wrong.
Well,
it's because it's so hot.
It's so hot.
And that's why the earthquake last night happened around 10 at night or whatever
because the ground gets so fucking hot and then at night it gets cold and that,
that con,
you know,
shift shift.
That's earthquake,
earthquake,
seasoning.
That's what it's made of.
Like hot and cold.
Neil degrasse
Tyson.
I'm going to try to get that dude on the pod coast.
Neil degrasse Tyson.
The scientists were going back and forth.
Get Mr Wizzard,
Mr Wizzard,
who's at,
I would love that dude.
Mr Wizards ruin.
I'm going to get doctor Steve too from the opie and Anthony Channel guys.
Fascinating.
He listened to his show the other day on Sirius and I found out why chocolate
kills dogs.
It's the caffeine.
It's a caffeine and chocolate.
Apparently chocolate has caffeine in it and the caffeine and chocolate.
Just Jack's dogs' bodies,
so don't give your dog Starbucks or cat.
Right?
Give me a cat chocolate.
Yeah.
That's good to know because my daughter told me there's something else you can't
give it to you and John Rollo.
Most unlikely cat owners ever,
I guess meet to a lot of people get talked to John Rollo all the time about
cats.
He's excited.
He just got something else to do.
It got to,
he just got something else.
He's got the billboards.
I'm going to go see him.
Yeah,
he's a criminal to go to Baltimore and Sam.
So I'm pretty excited.
Yeah.
We haven't had a UFC in that area.
We haven't done like a Baltimore USA.
Baltimore's aren't doing so good.
Right.
You know,
when I first got into comedy,
one of the clubs that gave me working for them see was a Baltimore Club.
Remember the Improv down there?
Did you ever do that?
No.
They had a good Improv,
their improv down in this kind of crazy area where there's like a lot of
different clubs.
You know,
it's like this little,
uh,
little patches of,
of fun places in this world where people figured out how to do something right.
But there's something cool about when you go to a place and like all these
different places all empty out into a common place,
like a courtyard area.
As long as everybody can keep their shit together.
Baltimore,
that's also,
I think,
wasn't it that the same place where that dude got knocked unconscious and they
fucking filmed it and they took his clothes
off and made a video of it.
It wasn't that Baltimore,
I think it was,
they shot the wire there.
They shot the wire that,
yeah.
Yeah.
Boston was duly fucking duty.
Fucking city.
Yeah.
They got some wild shit to the stadium,
the stadium and a couple of times,
great big government is going to want to disarm Baltimore.
Yeah.
That's some crazy motherfuckers.
Baltimore,
Philadelphia.
That's where those,
that's where you give those people guns cause they'll shoot anybody Delphia
don't feel it's the only stadium.
If they had a fucking jail in the stadium,
the football stadium,
I hate.
Did you see that?
That that coach got uh,
uh,
you know,
my condolences to the guy from Philadelphia,
that culture,
Ryan,
his son died.
He was on our fucking show couple of years ago,
Bro.
He was on a show.
That kid came to our show.
The kid who just died there,
the coach of the Philadelphia Eagles,
he came to our show.
Him was in talking towards the back room and that Atlantic city,
that was when,
uh,
the guy,
Tim Silvia and um,
uh,
what's his name?
The coach from Iowa and uh,
uh,
the Pharma,
they will all down there cause somebody was fighting.
Yeah,
we went done.
IFL went down it and we show that weekend when I got on stage,
he came up to me all juiced up the kid.
It's like dog,
whatever you need,
we got you covered here.
My father is the coach of the fucking Egos.
All I got to do is make a call bench.
So the other day when I saw that,
I was like,
wow,
that kid,
unless he has other kids.
But that was,
yeah,
the shirt and a hat and he was very young.
So my condolences to the fucking,
Nah,
I don't remember.
We're looking down in the crowd and Henzel Gracie was there laughing his ass
off.
Asked to place.
Yeah.
Okay.
That was when the IFL and Enzo was something to do with the IFL.
Like a lot of us went,
Hari the IFL was an interesting idea.
Just he can't take the whole team thing.
It's an individual sport.
The whole team thing really didn't work.
It's like stand up,
it's just me.
You went to Mike Bench,
you can't do,
teams are standing up,
you come in and we tag team me and you should say that.
But we kind of do have a team.
We're the team death squad.
I mean,
right.
That's,
that's it is a team.
You know,
if you were really thinking about it,
all the people that we have in our inner circle that we considered a lot writing
secrets.
Yeah.
You should do.
Don't do it.
Yeah.
I mean it's kind of like a team,
you know?
I mean if anybody is,
in most cases standup is not like that.
But with us,
I think a stand,
this is very much like a whole,
a whole group of us were all identified by our friends,
you know,
Holla,
Holla.
So now we got Denver this week and we got Vegas.
Frankie motherfucking that God gets Henderson Donald's wrong.
I took good fucking car to Joe Rogan.
That's a great car down there.
I'm going,
you don't make dog.
Uh,
there's certain people you want in your life and there's certain people you
don't want in your life.
I don't ever want to Brown with Frankie.
I go,
I love that guy.
I liked Henderson and
the fucking time when he grabs his leg and he jumps up and throws that kick.
Yeah,
he's fun.
He's is let it gets,
can be,
but he's got ridiculous legs.
It's got legs for like a 185 pounder when he's 155 pound guy.
He's got weird legs.
He's,
he's just a bad motherfucker.
Tough,
tough kid,
man.
He fights really good.
God's and it makes them look not so good,
you know?
I mean,
he keeps doing it over and over again.
You know?
I also saw that fucking cut til my man,
Rory Macdonald,
Toronto,
huge 30 something stitches.
I want to see a rematch,
a pennys and a and Benson Henderson to,
Oh shit.
That was great.
A great fight.
And you know how much Henderson would get up for that rematch.
But this fight this weekend,
it's going to be amazing cause I'll tell you what,
that Edgar Kid,
Frankie Edgar finds a way that motherfucker finds a mine.
He's a little dog.
He's got a mind that is like,
he don't like losing,
you know,
and,
and he comes back stronger.
He comes back stronger than ever.
He should see you lead guy.
He looks fucking rain man.
Up to eight dribbler like what the fuck's rain man?
And you want to giggle?
He said about who likes you to fuck up?
He's a bad mother.
I just watched him as great.
Made it the second one.
The third one again.
The other,
yeah.
You gotta be able to keep that pace up too,
man.
You gotta be able to keep pace with him.
He'll,
he'll drag you into some deep fucking conditioning water.
You know,
that guy can do that for an hour and a half.
He's,
he's one of the best condition guys in the sport.
And one of the reasons for that is what we talked about earlier.
Frankie Edgar doesn't cut.
That guy weighs 155 pounds.
I love it.
I love it when he can win.
I love it when he can win,
but when,
when he loses and he loses because of guys bigger than him,
it makes you think like,
man,
I wish.
I wish you could do it at one 55 I hope you can do it at one 55 but you know,
maybe one 45 is your weight class closet songs.
He goes to talk 45 that could be one of the greatest fights him against fucking,
I'll go,
oh,
command.
I've said that to this day one.
I'm pushing for it.
I love it.
At one 45 in Vegas,
something,
you know,
you can't count them out,
man.
You can't count.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Knock him out by any stretch of imagination.
That kid like I can win,
man.
I don't want him in my future and my past him for you,
you don't need that.
And you're fucking white,
man.
I don't need that shit in my fucking life.
I love the fact that if I,
if I see him and then I see him six months later,
I look forward to seeing what,
what's improved,
what's,
what's gotten better because it's going to be better.
He's going to be better.
It's going to do something better.
He's going to have some move that you didn't expect.
Common.
Some lead right hand that you didn't see coming.
He's going to shift his,
his was wait a little bit differently.
He's going to do something better.
He's going to have a little bit more conditioning.
He's not like an asshole,
you know,
it takes time off and gets fat.
That's 40 years at genes.
Those kids from down the shore of just scrapping,
scrapping because the other half is the Guido's and all that stability,
but the other half of a lot of people don't know is those kids have to go to
like brick township.
Like what Mike Dolce when they got to go to these schools and they group for
schools,
group for schools.
You play black schools that I was six foot four and his Frankie Edgar wrestling
against these schools and they wrestle it weight categories,
but it's the same day.
If Frankie wrestled at one 35 that guy that he wrestled against was a lot bigger
than,
you know what I'm saying?
Wrestling was the most ridiculous.
Those guys from up,
the kids I grew up with would go down south and they walk all over that fucking
show up and eventually those kids nights,
40 years of portrait that every summer they got to fight somebody fucking beggar
and they do it and the rides down there,
if you've ever been done that there's a fight every fucking night and it always
includes a Guido from up debt against a regular guy from down there and the
regular guy who always takes him to fuck off.
We don't shows up with his buddies or juice stop,
take off his shirt.
I've been training and those guys down the show like shut the fuck up.
And he's one of those guys.
I sent it to him all the time.
Used to light people up and Mr Breakfast,
that's the hang out down there.
They all go down there with no shirts on that goal.
They breakfast.
How you doing?
How's the advice?
He's the guys that don't even work on their legs,
don't even care.
They don't even care about their stomachs.
Don't care about that lats.
They just working on their biceps.
That chest and maybe a little trap is hilarious.
It's hilarious at bay with no supervision.
Vinny,
come here.
Hold the fucking needle.
How much am I supposed to put in there?
I don't know.
Not just fill it up.
How big you want to get out of fucking my arms be fucking huge.
You know what I'm saying?
So shoot the whole fucking thing.
Nah,
but what if I showed it?
Shoot it.
We'll get more of them on.
That's how they,
I don't read instructions.
They don't read nothing.
They don't know about.
What's that?
Cycles?
No.
No,
not about psych.
No sites.
How many of these do I eat?
All of them.
How many in that dirty you to eat?
Like 10 of them.
Did I go wrong?
You got a headache,
you know that stem entirely and they live and they swapped,
blown when they fucking drink and whatever.
They don't have no.
You know why we talk about medications and supervision.
Just Shit those kids done jersey.
Don't give a fuck about what you know.
In other countries you could just buy steroids over the counter in like South
America,
there's a lot of places where you can just buy sterile Mexico alone.
These kids go down there and fuck my de Mexico.
Come on.
That's not even South America.
North America.
That's crazy.
That's 65 months,
my friend.
Whatever the fuck it is.
What is it about red ban?
120 miles and we got fucking juice.
What's crazy is that right Aaron?
That border,
you got all this military,
you got the,
the,
the air force base or what is it?
What is down there?
The Marines.
The navy's down there cause the navy and my nephew Mar,
right.
It's,
it's based on it.
There's a lot of military down there.
They can put the whole military down there,
these Mexicans or dig a tunnel here.
But think about that.
There's all this,
but thinking about this,
all this military and then surrounding all that military,
you know what it is?
Some of the richest people on earth and those people that live on that island,
Coronado island,
those are some incredibly wealthy people.
Donald Rumsfeld lives on that island,
Bro.
Think about that.
Wrap your
head around that.
So this is like super,
he probably lives in like 10 different houses all over the world with all the
money he's gotten.
But uh,
this,
uh,
this one area,
you,
you go on,
like if you like Google,
um,
real estate,
like in La Jolla,
like look in the toilet,
the whole thing.
It's amazing,
amazing,
incredible.
The most spectacular houses,
they increase multi-multi multimillion dollar houses,
20 minutes away from Tiawana is hell 20 minutes away.
And that's not an exaggeration at all.
How you can get in your car and you can literally drive for 20 minutes from San
Diego.
It was crazy beautiful though.
I mean,
have you been down there like on those islands?
Like,
I mean there's no Olufsen I love San Diego.
Let's get the crazy beautiful San Diego on the Mexico side is you cross into
Mexico guys right there.
Yeah.
That's fucking scary.
It's scary.
It goes from the five two dirt roads.
Well it goes from,
there's an immediate lack of a,
a feeling of a net.
Okay.
Cause there's a net when you're walking around in San Diego there's a net of
society and civilization and culture and like the biggest trust,
you trust people more like military base there to protect you.
I mean you not,
you don't have the police when you live there you have like the one of the
biggest military basis protecting your there.
So it's safe still to live there in San Diego.
No,
no,
I know for sure but I'm,
what I'm saying is that when you walk through to Tiawana there's this feeling
like the net's been removed.
Like all of a sudden I'm seeing all these beggars and all this weirdness on the
street and all these people.
What do you want Joey?
What are you doing?
Are you looking for your ass right in front of my face,
bro.
Respect.
Um,
it's,
it's just that when you do cross that border,
it's a very bizarre feeling that you're only 20 minutes away from the place
where all of the law doesn't apply.
All of it is gone.
It's all gone.
And now you have to live with this rinky dink set of laws from this other
country.
And you know,
you might run into a cop who says that you were speeding and you just got to
give him money because that's how they roll down there.
And,
and who knows how many fucking people are involved in and doing illegal shit,
moving drugs around and it's right there 20 minutes away.
I mean,
it's way scarier than the ghettos in America,
isn't it?
Wouldn't you say that?
Awana is scarier than most of the ghetto.
Always five minutes away.
But one thing,
I know tons of people that go the Tijuana all the time and I don't know anybody
that goes to like Harlem and all the time you really know tons of people who go
to Tijuana.
All it sound all the time.
Well,
I'll tell you what,
Anthony Bourdain went recently on a show and I really enjoyed that show.
It was cool because he met with a lot of cool Mexicans that live in Tijuana that
were like sort of giving them the real deal on how everything went down there
and took them to a bunch of different bars and it didn't seem to me to be as
dangerous as I thought it was or as dangerous is.
Everybody always publicize it,
but you've got to realize that it could get way at any moment.
It's,
it's,
it's you're,
you're living your party and in the country where shit is just way different,
it's just way different and you can get lucky and do it a thousand times in a
row or you could get unlucky and you be there when some drug lord is trying to
make a point,
like some dudes trying to move product and someone's trying to block him so he
decides the light as fucking nightclub on fire.
They do shit like that.
Like in Tijuana,
not until on a and M can coon,
there was a a sell coke on the beach.
Do they really sell coke on the beach.
We'd go,
why are we talking about sandals?
Tiawana no,
they'd come up to you and so you fucking blow on the beach.
But you know it's been decriminalized.
Everything's been decriminalized and Co,
which is really weird.
It's awesome.
Get acid in Mexico.
I am scan on the last time I was done.
By the way,
it doesn't mean it's legal.
It's not legal.
It's to be criminal law.
Yeah.
I think it's still a crime.
Why?
That is why when you do get caught with it,
you got to pay out the ass.
Cause I wouldn't let you go.
Sure.
It's not illegal my friend.
But maybe if you had a couple extra thousand on you maybe.
Is that what they're saying?
We can work something in my friends.
Yeah.
They don't want violence.
They want to keep this business going and it shouldn't be an understanding that
I just got to give you a little bribery.
Yeah,
that would do.
I would be down with that if I thought it was safe.
I love it.
I love every aspect of copying and my day,
I used to go to Ireland.
I go a four in the morning.
I like dark buildings.
I like all that shit.
I ain't going to Mexico.
No,
no,
no.
It's not.
It's,
I don't need drugs that fucking bad.
That's a complete different realm.
You could come go down there.
I know people have got,
other than getting beat the fuck up.
Okay,
ready?
He'll want,
I've gotten beat the fuck up.
We have a friend from the county.
We have a friend that's gotten beaten up one time friend who makes mistakes.
Hook a house down there and I,
no,
no.
He went down and got beat the fuck up.
Don't beat you.
You want to get beat up until now.
I have a friend who went there.
Where's his friend?
You want to get beat up Asian.
Is He Asian?
Well,
one of those idiots here.
They were on that run.
You know,
I don't want to go to,
I never went down there for Trump.
That was a fucking junkie.
I think that it's over a board when a thousand bad things could happen to you.
Yeah.
You can fuck out and bad things could happen to you.
I know Anthony Bordain walked around for a day surrounded by white people with
cameras.
Okay.
That's a big difference that you wouldn't be walking around and all we need is
one Mexican and say hey,
and that,
that dude from fractal the field and all of a sudden they come over,
hey,
follow us through a potty and we're doomed.
And then you're kidnapped,
you're kidnapped.
So you know,
I mean you're the one that turned me off.
A Phoenix,
Phoenix capital,
the firm.
What do you think that that comes into Phoenix from down there.
Yeah,
and when fee in Phoenix,
the whole deal with Phoenix,
since it's all about drugs,
that's what they believe.
It's about the rival drug dealers.
People kidnapping each other.
It's more kidnappings in Phoenix and there isn't any other state,
any other,
all those border towns,
Laredo,
they fucking light shit on fire on the radio constantly.
I'll pass all you gotta keep people from Mexico shoot
at the American side.
Sometimes too,
which is really crazy.
Like people you know,
report that they're building a hit by a bullet from Mexico.
I know people have gone down there to get volumes oxycontin's edition.
I've never dealt with them,
but I know they've gone on it,
but I know millions of people going on there for the juice.
Yeah.
Let me ask you something about the juice and Mexico was just Mexican juice.
Was this still the juice that you get here and they just sell it over the
counter Mexico?
That's the question I want to know.
I have no idea.
Like is this the deck of the Robin when I go to Germany that I get in Germany
that you shoot it,
get from Zadar
makes you very large.
The same deep wall.
Not very departure health.
That's what I'm worried about.
If you go to fucking Mexico and buy 60 be balls and they'd be ball or they'd be
ball plus,
I dunno.
I've never bought in any pharmaceuticals while in Mexico.
Oh,
so you've been down there?
Yeah,
I've been to Mexico.
I've been to Cancun.
I've been to,
uh,
we're outside of bed.
I've been to Tijuana,
but only very briefly.
No,
mostly I'm one of the places when you guys to about,
I heard that,
oh all went to a,
where she needs say is I went to um,
to see the ruins and [inaudible] so that was in Mexico too,
but this was before Mexico
problems.
Yeah,
back then I did an MTV spring break thing from Cancun when I was on for fear
factor and they have that on tape somewhere we should know.
It was just like,
here is a,
this band,
this band wine shirt.
I don't wonder what I was wearing.
I might've went shirtless cause I'm so small.
You did a Sandler.
I don't think I did though.
I don't think I went shirtless.
If I did,
how dare I were outside.
It was fun.
It was a,
it was a fun,
but I didn't know who any of the bands where it was.
Even back then I still was in the dark.
It's still like new bands.
It's so hard to reach me.
You know,
like if you're trying to sell me some shit,
I don't,
I don't really,
I don't listen to the radio.
Did you?
To listen to Ben Folds?
I want to know if you would like Ben folds.
I wonder if you'd like,
I've been living so far apart.
You got to think that every year a new couple of bands come along and if they're
good they stick around and there's no way you can keep in track with all of
them.
I just,
you know,
someone will look a great song,
we'll be playing and I'll go,
who is this fucking bans?
Awesome.
What's his song?
And then someone will tell me and I'm like,
never heard of.
I'm like,
oh my God.
They're like,
Dev,
the number one album in the country.
They've been the number one band for two years.
And I'm like,
wow,
I just,
I missed their whole,
I don't know,
I'm completely out of the loop.
I named Ben Folds.
He,
uh,
he used to be in a band called Penfolds five,
and then he left the band and his wife,
he has a CD that he lives in Australia,
Australia now and he has kids and a family and uh,
he moved there and now he just,
he released an album that he played every single instrument on,
on the CD and then combine them into one.
And it is some of the best,
like music music wise.
It's some of,
what kind of music is it?
It's just jam,
like very,
you know,
a lot of pianos it's jamming.
Like you've,
if you've heard,
if I play you a song,
you'd be like,
Oh,
I've heard this before.
Uh,
he does this uncle like rock in the suburbs,
you know,
and shit like that.
I have no idea what the fuck you're talking about,
but I want it.
I would love to see if you got got into that or if he hated it.
Kind of like a grateful dead kind of guy.
I've never hated the debt,
I just couldn't get into it.
I just,
it just,
to me it was just,
it was almost like I was out of tune with it.
I couldn't get,
I know they say and there's the way that Dennis told me,
I like,
I like
working man's dead.
I like,
uh,
on the mountain fire on the mountain.
A couple of songs I went to see him with Santana and public enemy.
I don't fuck around at red rocks,
but they are a little,
their whole repertoire is kind of,
it's so much.
It's the fans that always startled me.
Dog.
Yeah.
I lived in boulder.
They pull up with a bus.
They haven't showered in the fucking six months,
you know,
that follow with this band,
you're looking at them,
are they really dirty or they hippies.
Half of them are trust funders.
Hi.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
aw,
fuck cooperations.
But meanwhile that's how they're living off.
That's fucking credit card.
Sneaking showers.
Meanwhile,
they drive a beamer,
but they either round the corner.
Oh yeah.
Boulder's very unique.
You know,
a lot of kids get to boulder in the anti fucking cooperation,
anti money.
Meanwhile,
your dad owns fucking Pepsi.
And you know what I'm saying?
Get it together.
You've done a little fuck before I smack you.
There's a lot of that rebelling from their successful frog.
Well fuck him.
You know.
But meanwhile you got an Audi and you haven't worked the whole time he head and
you're buying big bags of wheat,
cut it out.
There's a weird balance between like your,
your parents being successful and your parents being a good parent because of
the parents really successful.
They probably have to work a lot.
And if they work all the time constantly,
they're probably not going to be around as much.
They're not going to be as good of a father.
And if you're not going to be as good,
if you can dedicate more time to work than you are to your kids,
your kids are probably going to grow up to fucking resent.
Yeah.
You know?
And that's what happens.
You get a lot of these trust fund liberal.
He was fair for me.
He never went to another bank ballet checking back check and balance on your
account.
What's in the fucking account?
Did you have a lead?
I think no,
they shut the fuck up.
Cock sucker.
I have a friend that grew up with and every time he had three beers,
my father never went to another my football games really look at the nice
sneakers.
Yet you had a fucking 300 Zx in fucking high school,
your first car and you still bitching about your fucking parents.
You know they can't do everything,
Bro.
You can not be the perfect parent.
You cannot or you could do is fucking try because somebody is not going to be
happy with your fucking job.
I would hope that you can teach your children to not think like that.
I would hope that you would teach.
You'd be able to teach your children to not blame.
Your parents are paying for the last aspect of your life.
It'd be nice if your parents,
everybody's parents were around a little bit more,
but what does that sound?
You guys hear some sound?
I think it's true.
It is is fine.
Is that your phone Joey?
I think,
but I had it off.
Yeah,
it's sweat,
which was my bitches is calling me and shit
wasn't a phone call
cause I,
it was like muffled in the distance and it was confusing the shit out of me.
I got a text from Joey,
Dan's going to die.
I did Tim.
So he's amazing.
He has his text.
No,
no,
no.
I'll tell you what happened.
That's what you gonna do.
You to start tweeting like that,
like a stripper and went,
went to Ralph's.
Oh Em gee,
it's packed in here.
When you call this number,
right?
Let's say you saw me right when I,
sometimes I'm in my two of my pocket.
It's in your pocket.
Right?
So when I go in and there's a thing of the bottom that slides up and it gives
you all these excuses.
Oh right,
right.
So when people call you,
so I dunno what I'm pressing right.
Cause sometimes people call me back and go,
dog,
I called you,
you sent me back,
you went through,
what'd you go see?
You're talking about it.
You just text me.
You went to cinema
cinema.
I would say about the movies.
[inaudible]
that's the one I always practice.
It's fucking set him up like that.
There's a budget and I'll show it to you so people keep ticking on.
Joe.
He texts me,
he's texting me.
I don't get dads don't get carried away when you actually sent me a real bad,
you don't want to talk me out.
Fuck it.
I had to ask the kids daughter to teach me how to text on my phone.
He's five.
Really?
She's fucking fives.
I'm like,
I don't know how to text him.
It took the thing from me.
She goes,
who do you want a tax?
She went through the whole thing,
but she hit applications.
What to the fucking mess.
What kind of phone do you have there,
Joey?
What is that?
An android pharmacy for whatever the fuck it is.
How old is that?
One?
Six months.
Six
months.
It's crazy how much phones are progressing,
how quick they get that galaxy s three that just came out and um,
my,
uh,
my friend Matt has and I was fucking around with it the other day.
It's amazing,
man.
Holy Shit.
His eyes,
first of all,
it's fast.
That shit like it's really smooth when you back and forth between the,
the,
the menus and when you open things up,
the speed of it is really fast and the pictures are beautiful and the video was
beautiful.
I didn't screen.
It's fucking huge man.
When you start a watching like videos on it or watching anything on the Internet
on it,
it's um,
it's nice to have flash to it.
Kind of interesting,
interesting to say.
Very nice.
They have some bad ass fucking phones now.
Alaskan eat my ass.
He dies.
I'm,
the flash is getting worse and worse and worse.
It's gotten to the point now where my,
my,
my computer and I found out this does it on the alien.
Where does it on like every computer that uses flash where like a lit up a flash
movie in your whole computer just kind of freezes for like a second.
Yeah.
And then it,
then it kind of catches back up at the flash.
If you look at your,
your,
um,
your computer Cpu Monitor and then you do that,
you'll notice it goes up to a hundred percent,
from like 10%.
How is a dual core,
whatever triple court fats,
top of the line computer like,
like that.
It can't handle a fucking flash.
I don't,
yeah,
I don't know enough.
Last computer die eat aids.
I don't think you're going to eat it.
It's so fun.
I think if someone can give you a bowl aids and you could be fine.
So let's put flash on your fucking phone goes in that way.
I'll bowl of a scoop of a bull aids.
What do you think?
What color would it be?
I'd say yellow.
So why don't we,
why don't we enjoy like let flash onto our phone.
That does,
that seems like a good idea.
Let's just change the subject like everybody else.
Go with the flow.
You fuck it's flash thing.
He's obsessed with them.
But what's flash?
It's just a program that you run on the um,
on a android phones that you can't run on apple iPhones.
It's essentially a animation web animation.
It looks like little videos.
Youtube used to use it,
but a lot of what they use now is a html five and they also have it directly for
the iPhone.
So you just,
anytime you click on a youtube video you have like a youtube application that
opens up,
recognizes most new videos like pretty quickly.
It's like,
Hey,
my phone also has a floppy disk and the iPhone doesn't so well.
Yeah,
I definitely,
I definitely think that it works really seamlessly on the iPhone.
The uh,
like when I got a youtube videos and shit like that,
he works pretty fucking smooth and it would have to be,
I would have to be really impressed with how well it worked on the droid to
think about switching over just because of that.
I tell you that the hottest thing,
hottest thing.
And Mac Technology,
I'm just kidding.
The hottest thing right now,
I think it's cool
is the new operating system
that the new operating system,
new Mac has a screen sharing on it.
So you just like,
you can just hit this button and in any TV that has apple TV,
it's sends your monitor to the TV now.
So like if you want to work on it,
70 inch resolution screen,
you just on your laptop or whatever,
you just hit this button and it will flip it to your TV.
So now,
so I'm sitting there watching youtube or doing websites and love watching videos
on my,
on my big TV brands going to break our,
all of our brain's gonna break do the integration and the technological
integration.
It's just getting too crazy.
It's getting nuttier and nuttier
Joe Rogan,
I gotta give you something.
I forgot.
I've got a video for you.
What is it?
Oh,
oh,
oh what is it?
Pink Floyd live at Pompei Echos?
Yeah.
Oh they fucking go out in that,
in that arena in Palm Bay.
Put on hold real quick.
Tell me what it is again.
Pink Floyd live at pump pay.
Just put echoes pink Floyd that goes on.
They'll say live is pump pay and click it up and fast forward the video to like
two minutes.
Pink Floyd Echo's part one.
Yes.
Live at Pompei.
It's got to see it live it pump at hold on.
Yeah.
No.
Who the fuck went to pump?
Pay?
Anybody even know what Monday is live would pump out here in this part.
One is in Pompano.
And how far do I go in?
Go in like two minutes into the video.
What you want to do it.
This is this little,
uh,
it also has a lock and go to you just stream and shut this off.
Hold on a second.
It's got what I got to go to Ustream is shut off the volume.
Got a CD and I seen this movie as a kid on acid and the other night somebody
sent it to me and I went to youtube and I had to watch it three times in a row.
Where do I tune into it?
Go two minutes into like,
well it's let it set and then just watch these motherfuckers.
I mean this is,
it's a some Greek statues.
Oh yeah.
This is their outlet though.
If you had a fucking time machine,
this is really cool.
If you had a time machine,
what culture would you go back and watch the Greeks.
The Greeks.
Why is that?
How fucking cool was it?
They had that coliseum.
Where Bruce Leaf.
What?
Just not solely fucking things.
Rome brother,
whatever.
Same thing.
The Romans,
the Corinthians.
I'm confused.
Dog.
Who's the Corinthians there?
It'll wash.
Um,
that's what they became.
The Romans became the Italians.
The Corinthians Corinthians become,
yeah,
white people wash.
Is it French?
No,
they're the ones Jesus talked to first.
But Jesus told the Corinthians.
Yeah,
I thought they were fucking white people.
I don't like Anglos.
I don't know.
I've,
I've rejected all my teachings of my youth and they have so here,
but um,
he's uh,
yeah,
this is,
uh,
this is a weird thing.
Why are they in Pompei?
They're doing a live out,
but just,
just give it a minute.
Listen to this fucking music though.
Like on a steaming island.
Oh God.
It's amazing.
Dog shares of a Greek gods.
I would pick ancient Egypt.
I would pick Egypt over Greece,
but I think Bruce would be pretty dope too.
But I would like to in the fucking right when the pyramids were being built,
I would love to have gone to see what the fuck they were living like they keep
finding shit that keeps pushing back the date of civilization later and later
and later.
He found tools recently and proof that civilization is at least 20,000 years
older than they thought it was.
That's a big jump.
20,000 years.
A big goddamn jump
and there's still fine and stuff all the time.
Who knows how much stuff is still buried in Turkey.
I know Turkey is where they found Troy Turkey's where they found gold.
Beckley tamping turkeys when they found that statute.
When the exorcist.
Yeah.
More the two bars fight.
Not In the fuck a wilderness.
Well you watch that again.
I always talk about it because it's such a well made movie.
Oh yeah.
When he's in Arabia and Africa.
Africa.
That's where the devil lives.
Devil lives in Africa.
I know cause bro,
everybody lives in Africa.
All that shit's got in Africa Bro.
It'll all,
this whole party started in Africa.
If you look back,
look at it.
It off in Africa.
When you Brian,
where's your dog?
Man,
you shut that door so she cannot catch it.
Okay.
I just want to make sure she doesn't eat catch it because that's rude.
It's grass.
Another thing they found recently,
man,
I wanted to talk about this.
They found evidence that a mass amount of people were killed in London in the 15
hundreds by a volcano.
London volcano does.
I was,
uh,
in the middle.
I was running out the door when I read this and um,
I didn't,
didn't get a chance to really look at it like deep in there,
but this is apparently it's a recent discovery and what,
what they're,
what they've decided is that,
um,
they found thousands of skeletons and mass graves in London's east end and they
believe that many were victims of a 13th century volcanic eruption.
Hmm.
I'm not nuts.
That's fucking crazy.
Yeah.
They found,
um,
wow.
This is amazing,
man.
The skeletons were uncovered next to a s.
Wow.
This is a weird word.
Spit of fields.
Bill fields.
It's a bit of fields market.
When the news,
new,
spittle,
square one.
What kind of name is that new spittle square,
um,
development we started 20 years ago.
So I guess they,
they started digging and they found that shit.
And now a 10 year ecological investigation by the Museum of London has
discovered that the likely cause to be volcano,
which led to world temperatures,
cooling down and crops failing,
resulting in a mass starvation.
Holy Shit.
10,500 skeletons dating from the 12th to the 16th century were uncovered by the
archeologists,
including mass burial pits that had scientists baffled because the radio carbon
dating didn't match known events in medieval England,
like the black death or the great famine.
That's incredible.
This is 1258 there was a colossal volcano in 1258 wow.
This is amazing,
man.
So this is a new discovery that such a,
a massive global,
national,
natural disaster has been identified in a small area of east London.
That's incredible,
man.
That is amazing shit.
Yeah.
We don't know too much.
You know,
when they,
when they really talk about history,
like what we really know about the past,
man,
we don't really know that much.
We don't know.
We just make a fucking assumption.
We dig,
we dig,
and every other week we come up with a new fucking assumption.
It's amazing how much we're fine,
but that fucking take either that looks kinky,
come eat too.
I don't think that's fair.
And who gives a fuck?
You got to go to bars now.
Now $14 billion.
A lot of shit.
We got going on this fucking country.
Mars for what?
Who gives a fuck about Mars?
I'm sitting there going,
this is who Gazeena this fucking the tape.
They made this in Burbank.
Well this is what I think.
I think first of all,
yeah,
they did go and it's awesome.
And when you spend money on scientific innovation for space travel,
you're dealing with the cream of the crop of people that are trying to figure
out how to manipulate space and matter and and transport things and how to,
you know,
I mean you're dealing with the most,
the,
the most knowledgeable scientists on earth that has right to be strived.
And Suzanne.
Joey,
come on.
I mean,
I'm serious.
I'm saying silly.
This is what every,
let me tell you that everything that they do when they got to go to fucking
place,
I ex what it has to do.
We got diseases.
We've got fat kids running around and [inaudible] march.
Definitely we should pay attention to the IRC.
We should go and explore the universe all burn me a little by little.
We'll fucking dying.
He had dog.
This country is fucking dying.
We got time to,
I don't give a fuck what goes on at Mars.
I don't give a fuck what goes on in Oakland and loved it either 1529 I'm from
the Church of what's happening now,
mother fucker.
If you care about that shit,
you got too much fucking time on your hands guy.
What's that got to do?
We've got kids.
We've got houses.
Shut the fuck down.
You've got billions of dollars to go to model.
Give a fuck about,
I know this.
Why don't you get this excited about the wars?
Because that costs a thousand times.
I don't get excited about mother shit because it doesn't have what the fuck that
that they'd been fighting for 10 years and I'm still paying $5 for a fucking gas
guy.
The money we're spending on the war is a billion,
billion,
billions and billions of dollars every fucking year and how are we going to
spend more fucking money on going to Mars?
It's bad luck was going to Afghanistan.
That Mars thing is a positive thing.
The Mars thing,
they're going to get innovation out of this project.
I need them in,
in everything else.
It's going to eventually lead to,
I mean,
who knows what kind of space travel eventually we're going to have,
you're never going to go and I'm never going to go fuck.
It got nothing to do with us.
That's what the problem was.
I says,
we can't buy shit that got nothing to do with that.
This is why I care about it because it's cool as fuck.
When that thing lands on Mars and starts taking pictures and sending it through
the sky.
And I see a room full of people who've worked on nothing but this for years.
It's fucking awesome.
And I pick up an envelope at the thing.
All right,
you're going to jump up and down to somebody landed in market like a bunch of
fucking dicks that they were white with blue shirts on and shit jumping up.
And that's what NASA is.
Matthew understanding of the detail work put together.
And I appreciate travel.
You know,
10 years ago we hung out for years and you would talk about the moon landing was
fake.
Now all of a sudden you're happy about fucking Mars guy.
Come on,
give me a fucking break.
What are they all connected?
Cars.
Canal
that goes out of her day.
It's waste a thought.
We got bigger things to fry.
Gas is $5
a day.
We got this note routing guide.
Who's a fucking comic con uh,
water fuck from Idaho or Utah or the fuck is from again.
So Baba that's going on.
Good days,
his wife,
cause she's making fat.
Kids get fucking skinny.
That's it.
I mean,
what the fuck?
What the fuck?
We don't even have a prison.
We know we don't have somebody in a boat for the next four years and we'll worry
about fucking Mars.
Joe Rogan rarely about fucking what happened in England in 1529 we need to
fucking know what's going to happen at the next three years.
You know what,
Doug,
you're right.
I'm about to have a baby and I'm fucking scared because what is he going to have
in 40 years?
What are we going to have?
We're going to be getting fucked in the ass by Arabs,
but bunch of white people
go see if the Arabs are jumping up and down,
they're fucking gone.
Wait Til we get those wipe.
If they get excited like that about landing in Mars,
wait til they sniffed this arrow.
Bass Hall has their sucking my Dick Cause my learn.
How does my daughter have to learn Spanish or does she have to learn fucking
Arab in the next 20 fucking years?
That's what I'm worried about,
dog.
Does my kid have to go to school with 80 fucking foreigners or does she know
that's what I worry about.
So fuck march bro.
I don't want to hear about fucking Mars and a bunch of fucking waspy fucking
glasses jumping up and down cause we landed on Mars.
There's a of fucking mortgage is upside down this country.
Fucking painful.
The students.
Are you going to stop doing stand up?
No,
I'm not going to stop doing.
So why would they stop pulling with rover on Mars,
but what's mines?
That's when they join.
That's what they do.
That's what they know that I say eggs.
They're already on their art is creating something that can fly through fucking
space for a year.
That's great land fucking time.
And I think they pay me.
These mother fuckers are using my money to go to fucking Mars.
They take a half of your fucking check but taking half of my fucking check to go
to Mars.
Mother Fucker,
you get angry when you,
they take that money and they go to war.
I don't even think about it.
The war is something that more of that war we need.
War,
war,
fight.
What?
How much money do we make by going tomorrow when we put a put a Burger King on
mine,
we think we need more.
What are we going to put out cards we're going to make?
How are we going to pick up an envelope?
It's very in a Jew.
They're in a fucking Juliet's happy right now,
but what's going on?
It's Comcast is sponsored by ear doctors all across America and the conspiracy
copters and hired Joey to make people blow their ear drums out.
That pissed
so many things going on.
This is a closing fucking people.
He's a clone human pastors.
We got to go to fucking what bars to give a fuck.
Listen,
I ain't go Joey.
I support.
I support your Hubris on us.
None of them,
and listen bro,
I don't mind.
We've got to send pre Puerto Rican is,
I would have to establish a ride.
That's what needs to be done.
I'm going to blow up a fucking building or three black guys establish a wrap.
Wore his money to fucking bottom line.
The square root of war guy is Didas and we've all known that divis that's the
square root of money.
I don't see any divas and that's going to Mars except taking a bunch of rich
people and charge them to take them to Mars.
There's a quill and they explain you got
to every fucking drone is flying in Pakistan and taken out al Qaeda.
If you believe in that shit I made by scientists and that's if you want to argue
about keeping people safe,
the best way to keep people safe.
Look,
I'm not a,
I'm not saying I advocate drones because fuck load of civilians have died from
the use of drone attack,
but they eventually get that shit wire to the point where they can kill
everybody they want to kill.
That's where it's the scientists that are involved in making that shit or the
saint scientists that are involved in making all sorts of,
I love it and spacecrafts and Aircrafts and love technology,
man,
you want to kill somebody?
You make up.
I want to see the bullet.
I don't need a gun for it.
I just got to go like this and a hitching your head blows up.
I appreciate the scientist,
but not right now.
Billions of dollars to go to phone only Joey.
That is a tiny fraction of what our military budget.
It's a tiny tach for freedom.
What does Mars has to do with it?
It's a Martian gonna come back to Vegas.
That's a crazy thing to say.
The military is fighting for our freedom.
Is that why we're in countries that have absolutely nothing to do with us.
That's why and we invited them to,
come on,
man,
that's crazy.
That fucking flag brother.
What bad?
We got to kill some money.
You got to break a fucking few homage to fucking make an album.
You got to break some eggs to make a few of them that whatever they're doing,
it's a lot better than fucking,
they're selling drugs.
The CIA sells coke.
At least they make him money,
Mars and got,
here's the big thing,
Joe,
is that every time,
every time they send something to like Mars or the,
or do these missions,
they are also doing hundreds of experiments and these experiments are
experiencing that we can't do,
you know,
down on earth where do in a lot of these experiments lead to other things that
do help us out,
like cures for cancer and fucking time travel.
Well,
let's get the cure.
Listen,
just to be a dollar.
It's going to be,
it's going to come a point in time.
If we follow the path that we're on right now where we might not be living on
this fucking planet anymore,
we're human beings might pollute this motherfucker.
The point where we're going to want to escape and what they're gonna do is I'm
going to send shit to Mars,
to terraform,
just like they did in the movie aliens,
and they're going to put a fucking fake atmosphere on Mars and that's going to
bear a little escape colony graduate question you got to do with us.
You'll be dead.
Be Dead.
I don't care.
It'll be fun.
I don't,
you know what else to do it.
I'm alive right now and when something lands on Mars,
I get geeked out.
I want to see that shit out.
Looking at the photos,
I'm like that,
that land.
Has it ever been seen before?
Is that like,
is there have been people that have walked on?
It looks like fucking Arizona.
Well,
you know,
it doesn't really Arizona,
but you know there is,
there's a real theory that's a fascinating theory that Mars used to inhabit life
than it used to have an atmosphere,
but it was hit by an asteroid and that's one of the reasons why they want to
keep sending things there and get to task.
Because if it was a planet that supported life like ours,
but then it was hit by an asteroid,
we realize that we've,
we've had mass extinctions on this planet,
at least two of them that caused by asteroids,
you know,
hundreds of millions of years ago and then 65 million years ago.
They know that there's been some just doozies that have landed,
but it's possible that one could land that just kills the whole thing.
That's a wrap.
Let me ask you something,
Bro.
You up.
Okay.
Can you sell an asteroid?
Can You bring an asteroid to a check cashing?
Send a dog to get my fucking money.
Fucking ass to really going to vote for this year.
I mean,
I don't want to write in Doug.
Stan hope.
That's what I was thinking,
right it Doug Stanhope
and you see what's going on in this country.
We could get a lot of people that read it and go,
what's going on in this country?
Joe Rogan,
intelligent guy.
I'm a fucking Momo and I know that those both of them a bumps.
You're an intelligent guy.
You just looking at my face and told me you're not confident about anybody who's
running for president.
This country,
you and another fucking million people feel that way.
Well,
this is the real problem.
We feel that way.
They're going to have to,
they're going to have to restructure this whole fucking thing.
The way this thing works.
Now,
the first of all there was getting people to offices,
absolute horse shit.
This whole electoral college that might've worked when there was a hundred
fucking farmers out there in the middle of Pennsylvania,
and that's it.
It's shit that's not going to fly anymore.
That's stupid.
The electoral college is ridiculous.
It should be one person,
one vote,
one adult,
and she'd be able to vote online.
You fucks.
It should be real simple.
You should be able to register with a,
a personal id number,
like your,
your credit card information.
There should be some steps that you have to go to.
Authenticity,
authenticity,
authenticate,
authenticate your identity.
And then as soon as he hit,
they authentic you.
As soon as they get you and they identify you,
then you should be able to vote.
They shouldn't be some crazy electorial college and you have to go to some place
and your register and it's,
it's difficult to get in line to vote.
You got to wait and get off work and you're,
well,
I'm going to go vote,
so I got to leave now and beat the rush and come on.
And they're still stuck out here at 12 had a felony,
says 1987 and they're still fucking up sending me shit the vote though.
That's funny.
Well I got to go down there for months and argue with those people don't.
It's hilarious.
They send me be jewelry doing well then you do a background check.
Yes we did.
You're eligible for jury duty.
Can you believe that in a pan that you're eligible for jury duty?
Can you fucked your fucking 19 felonies and I'm eligible for fucking,
you had to pay an attorney to get you out of that.
Well,
I had a lie cause I had to call him.
I had a movie.
I was going somewhere else.
So you gotta do what you gotta do.
You know what I'm saying?
Sorry about that chocolate bar.
Fuck me up.
It's all right man.
I know what you're doing.
Just having fun.
No,
no,
no.
Watch the Olympics.
Fuck No.
I watched,
we talked about the,
these little men fly through the air barefoot,
like watch the little price on and I watched the,
I can't watch the basketball.
I watch the gymnastics a little bit.
It's interesting when it's happening.
It's sort of a,
what I like about the Olympics is it becomes like sort of a national festivity.
Like everybody's like everybody's rooting for us and excited.
Apparently the boxing team had the worst showing ever.
The boxing team didn't metal it all.
It is really fucked up.
It's
like a first time ever.
Nobody's boxing them.
I wonder if that's what people said.
Fuck it.
Shit.
I ain't,
you know what?
I bet you're right.
I was watching wrestling today when I was at the y.
Wrestling was on the side,
so I didn't really understand what's going on,
but the bottom now,
what happened with the,
the judo Cuban guy,
he hit the refaced hub.
Did you hear somebody who'd been done?
Yes.
A taekwondo guy.
I saw this basketball game where somebody just like,
like he seriously,
he just ran into the guy and pretty much almost punched.
He says ball out of it.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people getting fucking uptight.
I mean,
you think about the pressure involved and being in the Olympics,
you represent your whole country and flying through the air
and just trying to land perfect and that all your life has been built up for
this moment to practice all for this one moment,
just hurling yourself to the air flipping
fucking feeling.
It's gonna be insane.
It's gotta be a great feeling to what?
A battle.
It just got to be a great feeling to just be able to go to the Olympics.
Fuck it.
And just to win a silver,
whatever the fuck you do.
You think you could drop Michael Phelps off in the middle of the ocean and he
would find a way to get to the shore?
Yeah.
Do you think,
how long do you think it would take that guy to drown?
Three days.
70 days.
Seven days I think.
I think you could do two days.
No,
two days swimming.
A couple super athlete,
man.
He's a super athlete and it's saltwater.
Just float up the oceans.
Get a little boy.
Yeah,
he was swimming the pool.
When you imagine,
imagine if you get dropped off.
Okay.
To your right in one mile is an island to your left in 2000 miles is the shore.
And where do you go?
Do you go left?
You go right?
You imagine,
fuck,
I don't know which way to go.
But you don't know where the island is.
You don't know you're in the middle.
All you see,
you could get in a spot in the water where all you see is water.
Right?
And could you imagine that decision go left or go right?
How do you trust your instincts?
How do you not second guess yourself to tune yourself into true north?
I didn't know what the fucking land,
think about those fucking Cuban's Bro.
Oh yeah.
That build the shit.
And they tell him that you have,
and they have systems,
like there's people that have done it and then failed and gone back.
And these guys are like the people who come over and help you like this,
but you gotta do,
you gotta go dad,
you gotta leave at when the tide is high,
you just don't get in the fucking ocean and sweat.
And they have like a whole process.
You have to go on.
The tide is high.
There's not a blondie song when the tide is,
I want to be a no,
no.
You know,
that's why when you always set them at Nick Diaz,
Webster,
whatever the found out for trust,
man,
I gotta tell you that's one of the roughest waters.
That's one of the coldest water.
What are the most shocking fest awards?
You can be in a pool and it's 60 degrees,
right?
But once you jump in the fucking,
oh shit.
I don't know how cold the ocean is dirty.
Maybe it's cold as fuck
and the whole nine 30 but then it would be ice.
But I know that I fucking making slows down.
Yeah,
it does something to your joints and to your,
to your muscles contract.
So you're off
getting cold water.
It's really hard to breathe.
I was,
uh,
you know that dude who's a WWE star,
the Miz,
do you know who he is?
And now I think he was on like real world or something like that.
One of those shows.
But then he was a pro wrestler and he came on a fear factor once and I'm telling
you,
man,
we had a lot of people on fear factor,
but this motherfucker was the most fit guy we ever had on fear factor period.
Like no doubt he would do like hundreds of,
uh,
those bodyweight squats.
And he was a wrestler and like the dude was like in serious,
serious condition in cold water.
It was fucking freezing out in cold water.
This motherfucker jumped into a tank and did all this shit and moved all this
for two minutes and 20 seconds.
Everybody else had to go up for your hair and go back down,
go up for air and go back down this to just read and just jumped in and did the
whole fuck.
It's freezing cold water to smoke the joy in his life.
How he's been eating wheat grass and running hills.
Let me tell you,
someone you,
when I drowned at the y,
that time,
that's how I almost drowned because that's what got me,
what I wish.
I don't know why fucking seven years ago I thought the longest yard,
Bro.
Why told us,
tell the bid onstage that's ever told me,
bro,
you never told me.
You know,
when I was embarrassed and I went to the y one day I asked the guy to train me
and I got on the treadmill.
Michael only do three minutes while he sat me down.
He goes,
yeah,
you got to quit smoking and B,
I'll lose weight.
You can't.
He goes,
you got to hurt your joints.
If you walk on the treadmill,
he goes,
go on the pool.
And I'm like,
you're a genius.
The pool's not.
So I would go early and going to training pool,
which is 90 degrees,
right?
The water,
you're in the water.
Oh,
you get when you go and maybe be why you got to look at you.
You're doing back shit.
You're flipping up the water.
You're like fucking splash,
your throwing side kicks.
You're throwing punches like Muhammad Ali.
But one day I went and it was fucking,
uh,
the afternoon.
So I had to go into the Olympic Pool.
You've got to go sign your name.
And I thought,
you know,
I haven't been swimming for two weeks.
You know I could do this.
I got this.
That's what I went,
right.
I had swam in Boulder,
the masters from program,
so actually just could took a couple of weeks to get the the ship back to you.
I didn't know Bro.
I signed up and I jumped in the middle lane at the YMC Andy Olympic Pool.
Yeah.
That water's like fucking 42 or whatever it is.
As soon as I hit Joe Rogan,
everything just froze and my fat little legs were moving.
I wasn't moving.
I was just spinning around in circles because I think once the water gets cold,
it's even harder to maneuver in that.
Oh yeah.
I hadn't done it in a lot.
Listening.
Your body freezes up.
Listen Bro,
I'm Baldwin.
I'm the witness to this and bolden.
She does that class outside year round.
What class a masters from a program has done outside.
Oh Wow.
So when you get there on your bicycle,
they shovel.
Oh yeah.
So you run from the front.
So that's the pools outside.
I still got a change in the side of bolden.
Right.
Those crazy fucking wash walk from that hut to the pool and the snow,
they just parked the fucking snow,
you know that just they make a path and how pools heated to pool is heated.
So they just climbing the pool.
But the pool is awesome.
The pool's not that either.
Not Jacuzzi.
This is older.
This is James.
This lady was crazy.
It is.
Even if the water is heated,
it's still,
it's fucking,
when your head gets wet,
pop your head out and it's 10 degrees outside.
Even if the water is 90 degrees,
it's still sucks.
You don't see that fucking steam coming off that water.
But I jumped into this.
Why?
And I go into the middle and I'm trying to get out of that.
Joan is these two Mexican kids like Mr,
can we help it?
I'm like,
fuck yeah.
So I tried to pull me out and they can't pull me out.
So they go,
we'll get you,
we'll save you.
And they go and Austin and they brought her hoisting.
So a whole waste is what they put in the middle of the thing.
And they wanted me to swim back into the middle.
I was gonna go in there with my fat little Orca body and they were going to pull
me out like they pulled Orca.
That's a hoist.
Right?
Right.
And I'm like,
Dawg,
I'm drowning here.
I can't go back to the middle.
And then also they press,
they call the ambulance.
So the ambulance came,
but I didn't sign.
I ain't paying the 1800 I ran out of that before I,
I'm happy I got the fuck out of there before the ambulance came,
as they were coming in with the thing,
I was walking out.
Wow.
And I never went back to the why for about six months.
I was so fucking embarrassed.
I'm going to drowned at the Hollywood.
Why Bro?
Wow.
Just unprepared.
Just wanting to that water and it was cold and my lungs just fucking froze.
Stopped.
How often are you working on now for,
but I'm not swimming.
Did you change anything about your diet when you,
when we did that Mike Dolce parking?
Yeah.
I,
you know,
I liked the dolce stuff,
but I don't like,
I don't like a lot of weird vegetables I never have and I'm not going to eat
them at this time.
I'm not going to really fucking meet them.
You know,
I eat a man that had it done and that's really been good is I finally got the
spark,
was water in my kitchen and yeah.
And uh,
I don't drink shorter.
Good.
That's beautiful water.
That's beautiful.
And that a lot more water.
This is what you got to get in your head to water.
Tastes fucking good.
Water tastes good.
It tastes good.
You know,
it's not like cold calling.
Eat a soda.
Like sometimes warranty is better than soda.
Like he just in your head,
the sodas,
like the naughty thing,
but a meatball sandwich.
You got to get a beer with him.
You know what I'm saying?
Like if we're going to get a sausage sandwich right now,
you gotta get out.
You know,
there's certain things that you gotta get a cocktail with or a,
a fucking something water doesn't taste good with something,
has no taste too well.
When you're talking about for enjoyment.
For food.
Yeah,
for sure.
But like as far as like a clean taste,
if water was rare and you know,
and and may very well be some day and may very well be some day that our gen in
our future generations,
we fucked up so bad that water becomes like valuable.
I looked up you could only drink soda.
I did look up what you told me.
We were in trouble as far as why they leasing up these rivers,
bro.
We discussed it for water.
Water.
I think they leased out,
I don't know how many fucking rivers in 2000 for bottled waters.
Bottled water.
Yeah.
Well it's so funny if you think about water because you know,
water new water hasn't
been made for millions of years.
Yeah.
So like we're,
we're fucking,
you know,
drinking water that Jesus pooped out at one point.
You know,
the water just gets recycled and recycled and stuff like that.
It actually comes here and it goes towards to comes here and comets.
Yeah.
When you see a comment flying across the Scott at trail,
that's a,
that's a melting ice.
That's what that is.
So we get really small amounts of water from the earth,
from the earth was born.
We had been hit by you know,
many,
many different asteroids and many bodies from outer space,
but very likely you've been hit by giant slabs of ice from outer space.
And that the water that we have on this earth comes from other planets and that
every thing in this world is extra terrestrial because the whole,
the whole planet,
it's been created by things that have come from other planets that have been
sucked into it.
It's not like,
you know,
it wasn't like there was a thing and it was the earth,
the thing,
the earth was nailed by asteroids.
The moon was created because it was hit by another planet.
Like a lot of shit has hit it and comments have hit the earth apparently and
dropped water and that's like where all the water comes from.
Yeah.
But isn't it like on fire when it's entering the earth too big?
You know you're talking about a piece of ice that's who knows how many fucking
miles wide and it actually survives reentry and try to wrap your head around
that.
Try to have wrap your head around a piece of ice that can survive reentry.
How big does that have to be?
This guy is old and you live in boulder,
you know,
do all that.
You know,
you smoke dope and he'd go to old.
A lot of hippie things.
Let me just say one thing.
It might not survive the entry.
You might get burned up in the atmosphere.
It comes storms.
The fuck knows.
I don't know how many of them actually do land,
but I do know that the water that we have is from other,
a lot of it they believe is from like a pence barrier.
The idea that comes from asteroids,
so you can almost say that our waters could be being like ingredients added to
it from aliens.
You could be,
if you don't have water,
did come here,
come here.
It could have had biological entities frozen side of it,
so that's how they give us the firmware upgrades is from fucking comment water.
They're like,
all right,
we're going to,
yeah,
well that could be that.
That's what asteroids are.
It's like the reset button software updates.
It says reset button.
Let's why they had to get rid of the dinosaurs.
They got too crazy.
Like maybe the dinosaurs would be like a good idea.
It'd be like tigers.
We've kind of keep control of them but still maintain some sort of a
civilization.
But t rex just got way too fucking big,
you know this giant,
huge lizard.
Just run it through villages eating people.
So they had to just Jack Amal,
start fresh,
boom media impact.
One of those geniuses and bold.
I took a course from time and evolution,
just some shitty three critic thing.
This guy was saying that the world was a lot fucking bigger and circumference
diameter,
but over the years before,
well you were saying all the hits,
it's gotten down.
Really it gets smaller.
That's what he was feeling.
That's what his theory was.
That theory,
whatever.
This is 20 years ago,
but he was saying,
think about it.
He goes,
these were the bottom.
even when we walk around and,
and all those mountains where the bottom of that,
that was bigger at one time.
Yeah.
We feel,
you know,
these people,
whatever felt that it was big.
We just been getting it for the last million years.
It's really creepy.
So when you look at the moon,
because the moon doesn't have anything up there,
it's just this one surface color,
you know,
it doesn't vary that much.
So when you look at it,
all you're seeing is she's fucking craters.
There's no atmosphere.
So they don't get burnt up.
They just hit it.
So you just see doom,
doom,
doom everywhere.
The whole thing's just pockmark like,
like that dude's face from was such as names almost.
That's the guy.
Yeah.
I mean,
come on man.
If,
if that,
that's how many are coming at us.
All those holes that are on the moon,
if that's how many things are coming at us.
Some of those are big,
but there's some really big craters was the last time we got,
I don't know,
but speculation has been,
uh,
most,
most recent big one they think was about somewhere around 12,000 years ago,
10 to 12,000 years ago because they found all of this.
Um,
it's a type of molten rock that occurs during nuclear tests,
um,
and it also occurs during meteor impacts and they found it all over the world at
this same core level.
Uh,
when they do call a soil samples and then they go down to between 10 and 12,000
years,
I believe it is somewhere in that range.
That's where they keep finding it all over the earth.
And that's also,
um,
significantly when the end of the ice age sort of is like if you,
it's sort of coinciding with the same time,
like,
you know,
10,000 years ago,
that's when people were,
you know,
making their way across here from,
uh,
from Russia on the Bering Strait.
And that's when there's the,
the,
the whole ice age of a 10,000 years ago ended abruptly and a lot of animals died
in mass extinction.
Events like woolly mammoths,
saber tooth tigers died in mass graves.
And the speculation is that was the last big meteor shower and that somewhere
around 10 to 12,000 years ago,
you know,
most of the civilization got fucked sideways all over again.
A lot of people start all over again.
And that explains a lot of things.
It explains a lot of ancient buildings that nobody knows how the fuck they built
them.
It's most,
most likely that we had went on a,
we had gotten a very high level of sophistication.
I say we,
they the people in a bunch of different shit,
but um,
we went in a totally different path once we rebuilt.
And then our path when we,
when we rebuilt was a little bit more lost and became more technological in
nature.
But you can't deny the shit that they built.
Just this to stuff they built in in Greece.
You know,
just really look at the crop lips and the Parthenon.
You think these motherfuckers built that shit thousands and thousands of years
ago on top of some shit that was from thousands of years before that.
It might've been a super advanced culture.
You've got fucked up.
I immediately,
cause I get a little fucked up,
all this stuff that they have in Greece now.
Was this also part of Greek mythology?
Like Medusa?
Like why watch the clash of the,
I'm just asking you
guys,
when the fuck was clad,
not to the ship,
they came out with the original with Mark Hamill,
whatever that ball fuck his name is the original plan.
I think if I had to guess with the Greek gods were all about,
I would have to guess you have to have,
first of all,
some sort of an explanation for storms and you know,
we don't have to deal with too much fucking weather here in Sunny California and
we were getting pretty soft because of that.
But if you live on the east coast and you've been anywhere near Hurricane,
you know how God damn terrifying mother nature can be.
And if you're living in Greece,
I'm,
I'm assuming they get some sort of storms.
I'm assuming that they're leaders would have to have some sort of an explanation
of what the fuck is going on.
And I think it's a form of expression in the and creativity.
They figured out a way to create Thor and Zeus and create this whole myth
mythology behind it.
And it was probably just a calm,
everybody the fuck now and keep everybody together.
They probably had to have some sort of an explanation.
What is the lightning,
what is this?
Oh,
it's a guy named Thor.
He's the god of thunder.
Okay.
He's up there and he's shooting lightning bolts down.
He's actually in a fight with his brother who's a dick.
His brother's name is Loci.
LOCI wants to run shit and he's an asshole.
All right,
so what about gladiator?
And then there's move.
That shit wasn't that one.
Zoosh was around Odin and then there's Odin gladiator.
Was that one?
Zeus is around,
not even the same gotry that's role there was as the Roman gladiators.
Yeah.
What's his face?
The actor.
So he was his last great movie,
right?
That was the best one he ever did.
That was the best.
That was iconic.
That's like a,
that puts him in list of all,
what the fuck is his name?
Russell Crowe.
That puts him in the list of all time.
Greatest movie stars is a handful of five or 10 dudes.
He's right in there.
That's a great fucking was amazing.
I loved them.
Amazing.
We love,
you know what else was great in that camp,
that cigarette movie,
that's he,
that guy can really abandoned himself into a part.
He's one of those few dudes,
those few dudes at Chameleon.
But you know with that too,
right?
The inside,
yes,
but Chino.
But Chino plays the reporter from 60 minutes to hold.
That's right.
And his boss was Glenn,
whatever.
He's fucking good.
Yeah.
I,
I still appreciate the fuck out of a great movie like that,
but it's,
man,
it's just,
it's hard to,
it's hard to find a good one.
It's hard to find them like that.
You know,
you ever go back and watch like a movie from the 70s when they were really like
art pieces,
you know like they had big art pieces like Lamons do you ever see Lamont's Steve
Mcqueen and watched our recent little bonds is fucking,
nobody even talks for the first like 15 minutes of that movie.
It's a bunch of shit happening where you watched them,
this guy live in his life.
I mean he's driving his car.
He doesn't say anything.
He goes to locker room.
I mean it's like you're,
you're watching everything go out there.
It's telling you a story without a single word.
It's really fascinating.
And I think if you're going to use the visual medium of movie IG,
that is one of the coolest ways to tell a story because
you don't,
I mean that is the one thing that you cannot achieve in writing.
I mean,
if you say that it can never live up to the writing,
well well this is where we're showing you things with no dialogue whatsoever.
You know,
like painting.
That's what like one of the best ways you can create with a visual medium,
you know,
to not even use the word why,
show me some shit.
Bait me into this conversation because you know where it's going to go.
Where's it going to?
It's going to go back to the best movies one where they made,
you know,
if you watch her best songs,
when were they made?
Well,
when they didn't really know what they were doing yet.
Lamont,
if I put Lamont on for fucking red band,
red will throw me out of his house because red band is part of,
uh,
you know,
today we want a fast,
like if you watch,
can you think from the 70s?
It's a tough luck.
The Godfather's easy.
The excesses is easy.
But how best was won and they did not have Twitter attention span.
You have to understand.
So when we tell him,
you know,
I watched your movie,
the great movie,
the friends addy coil,
what a crazy fucking movie.
And it's still,
if you're with the wrong people in the room,
they're going to go,
Joey,
you got to change it.
Before I fucked him flawless.
I learned that from him.
Anthony Bourdain too.
I was watching his show on Boston.
He did a show on Boston,
you know,
grew up in Boston site.
I was excited by it.
It was pretty interesting.
He decided to hang out mostly in South Boston.
Hung around and like,
like weird little places where you get lobster sandwiches and real boxing gyms
and shit.
But then he brought up that movie.
I had never heard of it.
Robert Mitchum movies from Moses from the 73 and this movie,
I mean if you want some ways a lot of character actors,
directors,
but those movies,
they're pieces of wood.
We discussed this with Charles Bronson comes up and he goes,
did you bring all ours for me?
No.
One horse,
you know to me fucked up.
Yeah,
well no,
you brought one to many.
One to that takes 15 fucking minutes.
That scene,
you will go Joey changes when he gets off the train to bell rings,
the Crow Flies.
Three guys walk this way.
Three guys walk this way again.
If you want to go back to movie,
bad asses all time.
Great movie.
Bad asses.
In my opinion,
no one can fuck with Charles Bronson.
You can't fuck with Charles Bronson movie.
Bad asses.
Legitimate real movie,
bad asses.
You know as far as like,
like a guy who really believed I believed him in hard times.
Okay.
You know,
I believe cleaning should a little bit,
but he did comedies like every which way but loose and when you do those,
there is a little something lost.
Charles Bronson never did a stupid comedy.
That wasn't that funny,
you know?
But still Vaughn has Stallone had that one with his mother.
Yeah,
my Momma Shit.
Yeah.
Stopping.
My mom will shoot.
What was the other one?
What was the point where Russell,
he was a cop and it's one of the worst movies of all time.
The dialogue is so bad in that movie with him and Kurt Russell that people like
replay it.
They do it as like theater art as a performance art cause the the lyrics or it'd
be the,
the the words rather the,
the
the one he did with his wife Bridgette.
Neilson,
go ahead.
I don't shop you anyway.
It was that Cobra Cobra.
Oh he's fucking,
he had the craziest car.
This guy again,
I would have Dev,
the oldest guy you could get,
it's got to have glass.
You're going to be an old car.
He had this old shit box car and he's like racing people that are in like modern
cars catching them and we'll come on man.
I know he made his own fucking torpedoes.
He made good movies when he was young.
Fist was good to pull it out with a song.
The lords of Flatbush and yeah,
that was his first.
Henry Winkler put a ring.
Let me go outside ladies.
Let me pull up for this guy.
You know,
he talked,
they got was the one where he was the fighter,
not rocky.
That was was looking at Stallone.
He's,
he can act as fucking ass off.
He just does a lot of shitty movies.
They painted the one with the arm wrestled.
Oh,
I don't remember that cause it's Kinda the top.
Was that what was the one when he went to jail and he broke himself out?
What?
The car hit me.
The kid from King of Queens,
they had the call and yeah,
the Italian kid that used to hang out with Kevin James and that there's a skinny
kid and that go look it up.
He did a movie that came out.
I was in the halfway house.
91 90 what's the guy's name?
I don't know,
but it's the load.
That movie where he goes to jail and then dad,
they work on a car.
Okay.
Remember they worked on a car.
The car was fast and it brought him back and please,
please look it up because I'm not going to make it home.
God brought me back.
I had please,
I'm sorry.
What am I going to look up?
What did I say?
What did you even just say?
Just go to fucking Sylvester Stallone and look at 1990 and see what movie came
out and you could see everything we're talking about what you put on my glasses.
I can't do this.
I can't.
I want to know what this fucking movie is because you don't care enough to get
specific.
If you think that that movie you think is bad,
the one with karate with the kid,
the Bouncer,
you got watch road house.
This house is amazing.
This is a roadhouse is bad.
This is not bad.
Roadhouse is so bad.
It's good.
That's why Roadhouse roadhouses my favorite hotel movie.
If I'm flipping through the channels out of respect,
if roadhouse comes on,
I keep it on.
If I'm just flipping to the challenge and any other movie comes on,
I'll,
I'll see what else is on.
I'll keep changing much.
Listen,
but that day is the worst movie that you leave on because it's so bad when he
takes the wire,
when he thinks the guy's intestines and he flies out the door.
First of all,
why would you watch that?
Because I'm high and I can't find the remote and the hotel room lock I like,
I like a lot of friends that are Mexican,
so I got a one 80 lockup lockup.
Thank you.
He works on the car and then the warden tells him,
if you fix the car,
I'm going to shut your pro parole off.
So he has to beat up the award.
It's like the longest because trust me,
I tried to watch the new Ari and I tried to watch the new Sherlock Holmes movie
and we're like,
what
the fuck is this?
What did they do?
They do.
They just put this together in a week.
It's just,
it was,
it was like so clunky,
like the was clunky.
The dialogue was like these characters that that was cool.
If it was a book,
you know,
back in the old days,
but now it's like,
Hey,
do you want to see what we need with hardy boy?
You know what it is,
man.
They fuck it.
Do you have a Guy Robert Downey jr?
They got it right.
The first one.
I thought the first Sherlock Holmes movie was good,
but this,
the latest one was like,
what are you doing?
It's like a parody.
It was not good that that,
that new movie with Arnold Schwarzenegger or Bruce Willis expendables.
It's going to be awesome.
You think so?
Of course it is.
If you want to go see that kind of movie,
it's going to be awesome.
It looks hard.
I never saw the first one.
You know what that is?
That's a,
that's like a champ driving a muscle car.
Think it's just crazy to watch.
I saw the preview and heart source.
Anyway,
it goes back and I'm like,
are you kidding me?
He's really fun course.
He'll say that,
man.
If you're in the theater and he gets out there and he locks and loads,
he goes,
I'm back.
You'll go.
Especially if you were 14 you were thinking about that.
If you were 14 you were back in Ohio,
would you not go crazy for this moment?
I'd be like,
who the fuck is,
I don't know.
Sort of saying,
I don't give a shit about this dude name.
Oh,
he's in a shitty movie I saw on Hbo that one time.
No,
you know like kids,
if you watch terminator right now,
you're like,
who cares?
But they got transformers,
Arnold's Schwartzenegger and we think it's good,
but I
will not think that's good.
I watch superman the other day and I watched Batman with uh,
um,
uh,
be returned Batman or whatever the one with Michelle Pfeiffer and Danny Devito
as the joker.
That was horrible.
Almost awful to watch that.
Michael Douglas,
Michael,
Mikey,
keep make a case to think in my head.
No,
Michael Keaton was the best bet.
I mean,
I like Michael Keaton.
I watched off the biggest pile of shit ever.
I can't believe I ever thought that movie was good.
And I watched superman.
I was like,
this is the dumbest cheesiest fucking movie ever.
It's your prime to one of them.
Three or four,
I think it was,
but superman,
like here's like a part was like prior,
like this one girl,
like Lois lane that he pushed over the edge or something like that.
And then he jumped over the edge and then he went and got her,
got her.
But then he's like,
they didn't explain like he was Clark Kent or what's his name?
Character.
Clark Kent.
He was Clark Clinton when he jumped off.
And then like he supposedly like changed his clothes while he was falling and
then put his clothes somewhere and then like grabbed her.
It was like so many dumb things like that superman is supposed to be able to
move faster than the speed of light.
So he could do that Brian now.
But it was really horribly done.
I'm sure greenscreen flying over and you're just sitting there like this is so
fake.
I'm out of this movie cause your,
your guys are obviously not flying right now.
It was that bad.
So anyways,
you see a 13 year old kid watched that movie.
He's never going to get into that.
Yeah.
Well one thing that kids get
today though that they never got before is he get um,
uh,
a history of cinema like in a full form.
Like they get to see a vast difference between like King Kong from the 1930s and
a movie of today.
I mean it's a,
it's amazing if you watch,
if you're a kid today and you watch like old movies that they,
it's gotta be a real mind fuck.
Like how stupid were people that they thought that was cool?
We've seen it a little bit because I remember when I was a kid growing up,
I was really into special effects from monster movies and Harry housing.
I think that's guys Harrington was that the same,
whatever the guy's name was.
There was the animation dude who did like King Kong and Rick Baker and we did
all the shit for,
um,
he did an American Werewolf in London and like really cool,
like,
you know,
special effects type shit.
And I remember thinking like,
it's amazing like from the 1930s,
the 1980s like,
look at how much better they've gotten through the 1970s.
I remember thinking that.
Like,
wow,
they were terrible back in those King Kong days.
But you look at it now and through our lifetimes,
things have reached critical mass.
They've gotten really crazy to the point where you're seeing an artificial,
like everything,
like you're seeing asteroid impacts,
alien invasions,
all these different things in movies that look incredibly realistic.
I mean incredibly realistic.
Like undiscernible like you don't know what's fake and what's real.
I watched aliens the other night.
It doesn't hold up.
No,
no,
no.
The suspense still holds up.
But the,
there's a scene where the fucking spaceship is flying through the clouds and it
looks so bad.
It looks like a Saturday night live episode.
It looks like two inches.
The cat is driving the spaceship and I missed tune.
Says it didn't even look remotely real.
I was like,
this is so fucking,
it's so takes me out of this movie.
Like it's so clunky.
You know,
the other night I went to do comedy and I got home and as I walk in the fucking
door,
I sit down and to see who's on Letterman,
he was on level.
It's the first thing I do and something I scrolled on Hbo and its midst and
majestic.
Oh that's when they break Mr. That's when they break Charles Bronson's water
balance.
So I have a friend that's,
that's,
I have a friend that's a big Charles Bronson Fan.
I call him.
I go,
Bro,
it's 1230 here in California.
I was going to go to bed,
but I guess not Mr Majestics only they look,
he's asleep.
He goes,
dog,
what the fuck?
He goes,
that's my favorite.
Charles Bronson is going to be killing white people now call me in the morning.
He just hangs up on me within,
I timed it.
He started beating up white people at the 16 minute mark.
He's classic.
The first thing he did is he hit some dude and the Dick with a shotgun in his
body and then the guy was playing music on a speaker and he shot the fucking
speaker to get the Mexicans off the thing.
I fell asleep.
It was too fucking slow again.
That was one of those movie that was great and 1980 I had to watch it,
but you watch it now and it's funny cause when I first moved to Colorado and
aspirin,
they only had pay ESPN 12 one station and it was just getting started.
They played that movie three times a week or it was a six o'clock movie.
I watched it.
I was broke
because I would watch every night.
So I know that movie front and back,
it's just,
you're right.
It's just hard times alone.
Hard Times.
Death wish.
The mechanic,
the mechanic,
there was a couple movies he made.
Uh,
you know that story I heard about when they did the magnificent seven and they
all got together and they said,
listen,
we can't let this fucking Yule Brenner steal off fucking heat.
We're Americans.
This guy's the fucking,
well what we do,
they make the king and I.
Yeah.
And they were like,
are you kidding me?
Where's Yule Brenner from?
You'll Brendan's life from some other country.
So this was an American movie and it was,
you know,
Steve McQueen and James Coburn,
Charles Bronson,
and they're like,
let's torture this.
Motherfuck so they would torture,
you know,
they would fucking abuse them.
Call them up from the Formosa and tried to wake him up in the middle of the
night.
We'll come in and get you to hang up on him and shit.
Yeah,
man,
they got the gun.
They're like dog,
there's no way this motherfucker's gonna come over and steal his movie from us.
So they were fucking with him really?
Which I heard it.
I heard them.
I heard them talking about on TV.
That would sound the a biography one time.
You know,
they,
they didn't enjoy and see Scott insinuated it.
George,
he's got one old and he's like dude,
you guys to let some foreign to steal your movie.
Fuck this motherfucker George,
he's got this,
he's got guy.
You know,
he was a fucking,
he was the lit.
He,
he's,
he was in the hustler.
Right?
It wasn't George.
She's gotten the hustler.
No,
he's in the one about cards with Steve McQueen.
The Cincinnati Kid.
Look up,
look up the hustle.
I think he is.
Yeah.
He always played in those heavy mood.
He was,
no,
he was always a heavy in those.
Sure.
Yeah.
Cause he was,
yes.
He was always a heavy in those fucking unleash Jackie Gleason cause he was in,
um,
he was a friend of mine's brother,
like brother-in-law or something like that.
Have you seen that at trailer for the new Superman Nydia called man of steel.
There's a new superman movie that comes out in 2013 Russell,
what's his name?
Russell crowd.
The guy that was in gladiator plays Superman's dad and it's wow.
You can't beat fucking Marlon Brando was super bad.
I,
yeah,
that's the good part.
And I tell him,
well she was really good to superman.
Jay.
Uh,
what's his name is gene Hackman Hackman.
Who's getting it?
Yeah.
Thank God Superman.
Yeah,
he played Bert Gordon.
George.
See Scott played beat up Gore George.
These questions at the hustling,
he played a heavy,
you know,
you owe me money.
He was always a fucking heavy.
He was craving that movie.
Don't another movie,
the Hustler,
19 minutes.
It's,
I think it was 63 or some shit like that.
And that's another movie that was a,
it's a,
it's like you gotta like really have an attention span and watch that movie.
It's a different sort of thing.
There was a lot of subtlety back then.
Like a guy would like walk in and like look at the clock and then look at a guy
who worked there and the guy worked there would go over and change the clock.
They wouldn't say a word.
The guy would look at him.
Jackie Gleason looks at his watch,
looks at him,
and the guy just changes the clock.
You know what I mean?
It's like there was like subtlety to two movies back then.
Well,
they gave you a magic nation,
a director in the sixties seventies and the beginning of the eighties he gave
you,
he let your mind run away with it,
you know,
and I always say that scene in the of Marlon Brando goes down to director,
would have showed him this director,
pulled it back and let the wind blow and he showed the fucking things from the
fruit checking.
They didn't show Marlon Brando and the beauty of us,
he didn't shoot Marlon Brando straight.
He shot it this way.
So Marlon Brando was dead somewhere in that corner.
That's your imagination.
You're already judging like,
where is he?
He just died of a heart attack.
Where is it?
You're trying to look.
He didn't give it to you.
That was artistic.
It was a different,
you know,
that guy's a great fucking director and today we have a few couple of directors
but not that show you that imagination bro.
When you leave there fluctuate,
you had a little bit.
What's that?
What's going on now too is that there's so much money involved and making a
movie and there's so many different people involved in like their opinions and
they,
you know when you get a hundred million dollar investment in some crazy ass
move,
you got to,
unless you're James Cameron,
we could just run the show.
You know like a guy like you.
Like everybody goes,
Oh James Cameron,
he's a thug and tells everybody what to do.
He's an asshole.
That's what he has to do.
This is the only one way to make a titanic.
You have to have one guy who is powerful as fuck with a crazy vision because
otherwise you're going to butcher it.
You know you're not going to make an Avatar.
You've got to have one guy who puts this whole fucking wacky thing together.
The expendables is art.
No,
it's a marketing boy.
Well,
it's fucking guys took a pay cut.
They're going to make 200 fucking million and going to get a backup and they all
find a lot of say that,
but it is our children's roadhouse.
That's what it is with this stupid ass movie is going to be all these movies
that are like really fun and ridiculous,
even though they're pointless.
They're going to be a little funny shit that our kids laugh at.
Like how stupid is this?
It's like,
have you ever watched missing in action?
I'll praise be to chuck Norris.
You ever watched missing in action?
So there's a guy that I'm horrible movies,
but they're awesome.
They're awesome and they're horribleness charge.
Let me tell you something.
All respect.
The fucking homie made some good movies with Chuck Norris.
Chuck Marohn,
nars mates.
What?
What was that one cop movie that he made was,
that was super little shit in Chicago.
Loophole that up.
Yes.
We've that other dude.
Yeah.
When he 83 code salads,
code of Silence,
budget movie.
He was a bad mother fucker in that movie.
I'll put his performance in that movie up with anybody.
I play in a legit guy,
but he had to martial arts before that.
Barely even use much karate in that movie.
He like,
he had a kick a couple of ask it.
That was a real movement.
The Pool Hall,
he's the first guy ever before Steven Seagal,
that movie that he put the cool boy and the thing and started hitting people
with it.
Really us the Gao stolen out for justice.
We know.
Where's Bobby Lupo later on,
but double check,
but please tell me the name of Chuck Norris,
his earlier movies.
This is code of silence was in 85 85 that was a good move.
What's before?
Coatis army invasion USA.
That's Delta force garbage.
Oh,
actually those are after it.
Before that,
I'm sorry.
Oh,
won't lone wolf.
Mclass at what's before what lone wolf McQuade was still a karate movie because
that was David Carradine and,
and Chuck Norris would go out and at the end and the fucking ultimate
finale karate scene that you knew Chuck Norris is going to win because it's his
movie now.
There was no drama in that victory.
Oh,
there's a bunch.
Man is forced vengeance,
silent rage and eye for an eye.
The octagon.
That's a go walk to gun before the game.
What about this 1980 a force of one.
That was a good one.
That was a go one.
And what's the good guys wear?
Black.
That was a good one.
Fuck some people up in the beginning and then way back,
the first movie ever had was 68 the green berets and the wrecking crew,
he was like a party guest who was like,
had to let tiny ass role.
And then in 72 he was in the way of the dragon pitches and that's a,
that was it.
That launched him say giving broke.
He had,
he had more longevity cause to gout.
You tap that on the Gal after the Brooklyn movie.
Once somebody shot Bobby looper you're like,
I'm not putting up with this.
Fuck.
It's good.
Guys were blacked.
It really launched the guys good looking at his career.
There's like a couple of years we didn't do any movies.
He had 72 73 74 and then 75 76 seven and seven s so for,
for between 75 and 77 he didn't work.
And then he did break a breaker.
No,
no,
no.
That's when he sold tanks.
Trudeau.
And why was he fighting before 72 really?
Yeah.
Look it up.
Let me tell you something about Chuck Norris.
You know,
people joke around about Chuck Norris.
Chuck Norris back in his day was a bad mother fucking body and fun where the
Dragon,
he was allergic shit,
bad motherfucker back then.
I mean the level of a martial arts back then,
you know,
there was a few guys that were representing at the top level of martial arts.
He was one of them,
Benny or key does.
He was one of them.
There was a few of those guys back then and Chuck Norris was is legit.
I see Benny,
I get happy.
He's a great guy.
We thought when I see Benny,
I get happy.
I got to tell you that if you mentioned the bell yet.
No,
but he's,
Jim is one of those.
But you see at the gym every day and let them get you in a headlock.
No.
Is He at the gym every day?
I don't know.
I don't know a schedule.
By the way.
I stopped by at each school last night and I got to tell you something.
Ronda Rousey's very fucking Straw.
Oh,
she's a beast,
man.
She's very fun.
It shouldn't happen,
dude.
I was watching her.
He,
first of all,
he was teaching some high level shit last night.
He was on a row last night.
I went yesterday,
the day time and last night.
Yeah,
he was.
He's been on a roll lately.
He's been on the road,
but last night he was teaching some high level shit dark and when she packs that
food over,
oh,
she was powerful legs.
Mindful Lady.
Great.
Armando hormones are nasty man.
She's a strong woman.
Gosh,
she gets a hold of your arm.
She,
she knows,
she doesn't just know how to get an arm bar.
She knows how to correct as you're correcting.
So she knows,
she knows to anticipate,
like here for instance,
like this is the way to get a person in an arm bar.
You got to extend their arm like that.
So if you think that someone's going to try to arm bar you,
the first thing you do is turn your hand this way.
And the reason why you turn your hand this way is because then you straighten it
out.
You force it like to what they want.
They want
to straighten your arm out so you turn it like that and then go like this.
So that way when they pull on the arm,
it's going to go with the joint and it's going to bend and then that's their job
to try to turn it back around.
She's a master at adjusting that armbar like making sure that once she locks
her,
hold that arm,
she rolls with them.
She flipped some.
She's like,
if you watch her fight with Misha Tate,
or if you watch a lot of our victories when one of the girls,
he dislocated her arm and the girl said she didn't tap it or is Jack,
she,
Jack's everybody's arms and she,
she is a master at adjusting.
As soon as she locks that thing up,
first of all,
the speed that she locks it up as nasty as fuck.
Her technique is pinpoint,
everything's perfect and she's a master at adjusting.
So there's,
once she grabs a hold that arm,
you start flopping around,
but she knows where you're going to go.
You know why?
Because she puts on bars on people every fucking day of the week,
so she knows exactly what to do.
There's certain positions that when you get used to,
you know how a guy can get out of him,
you know the defense.
Like if you first learned a rear naked choke and you've never choke the guy
before,
the guy gets a hand on a 10 he turns the next thing you know he's out and you
don't even know what happened.
But if you get good at it,
you know what a guy can do to get out.
And so you stop all that shit from you anticipate it and the more you roll,
the more mat time to get in.
The more reps you get,
the more time you spend actually choking people,
the better you get at that.
It's just no way around it.
Or Rhonda has got to that point,
that master point.
You know,
there's a point that someone gets to a certain moves,
like with Cody Mackenzie's that crazy guillotine.
Tina gets people with Rhonda.
It's that nutty armbar man.
And she's got a lot of other techniques and her defense is good too.
Cause Misha Tate is also a bad motherfucker and me should take out her back and
she got out of that,
you know,
shows you that her defense is good as well.
But,
uh,
we should say five next.
Let me see.
I think so nimble.
Um,
Ron is fighting Sarah Kaufman,
so I love Misha tape,
man.
I follow on Twitter.
I love women's fighting.
Man.
I didn't use to love women's fighting.
It's to a different level.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
See what does her should say next opponent?
Hold on as a great movie to watch his fast night while smoking shit loads a
weed.
It's the most trippiest fucked up movie I've ever seen.
It's called a funky forest.
Okay.
Hold on a second.
Cause I want to answer their question.
Her name was Julie Kedsey.
That's it.
That's who she's fighting.
She's Miesha Tate fight.
Julie Kedsey and isn't a strike force and it's an August.
They're fighting a August 18th.
Her uh,
her boyfriend just fought in the UFC and one right?
No,
me sharing CareWeb but what's,
uh,
I'm sorry.
She's fighting a little show.
Whoa.
Ronda.
Ronda Rousey's fight and Sarah Kaufman that same night.
Is it same night?
Yeah.
Can you please check?
I think it's from August something.
Um,
I don't think so.
I think,
I think uh,
Rhonda is funding another time.
So there's two different strike force think.
So I'm not sure.
I feel like,
uh,
Rhonda is fight is a,
as next is a,
the next month I believe.
Let me check though.
Ronda.
Rosa.
So what happened Brian?
You got,
Huh?
I,
there's a movie
called funky forest,
the first contact,
and it's a hilarious movie.
You know,
it's just a great movie to watch when you're super stoned around mushrooms.
It's the,
if you go on Google or on Youtube,
you could watch clips of it and if you,
if I showed you it,
you would fucking freak the fuck out.
Oh,
okay.
This is August 18th it's the same car I knew.
Wow,
that's crazy.
That means it's going to be too big.
Women's fights on one card.
I thought they would space it out.
Well,
you know what,
man,
the reality is,
Rhonda is such a Badass that there's been a lot of attention on the women's MMA
movement now there where there wasn't just a year or two ago when Gina Carano
stopped fighting when she stepped out and Rhonda,
the other theaters,
I Rhonda,
it's like stepped up to Cyborg like a bunch of times.
So if you've never seen,
if you don't know what the fuck we're talking about,
there's a woman named Cyborg.
If you were a chick and you were fighting,
what would be your biggest nightmare?
So your biggest night would be a woman who's not attractive,
who looks like a man,
is built like a man and she knows how to fuck people up.
But I saying that,
yeah,
I don't want to go to Woolworths.
And that's almost exactly what Cyborg is.
It's fuck.
And she tested positive for testosterone and male hormones or whatever.
Whatever she had taken whatever banned substance that she had taken.
It wasn't it?
I think it was Anna Bar,
but I don't remember.
But whatever it was,
it's some sort of a,
a,
a steroid,
which is what everybody at accused her of everywhere.
Uh,
anyway,
so Ronda Rousey's center,
uh,
you have a Dick,
you dick,
she uh,
she said a picture of Gina Carano Cyborg did cause Ronda Rousey said that,
you know,
you know that she was a cheater.
So she sent a picture of,
uh,
of uh,
Gina Carano when their face busted up after Cyborg,
beat her up and she said,
you have a deck you'd tick,
which is pretty fucking funny.
And it was just,
if you really think about it,
if she really wants cheating,
and that's what she did once she was cheating.
Like if you really,
it was,
I mean if you,
it's really not that many.
We talked about on the podcast,
we even had a doctor who had doctor Steve Call up and explain it to us.
Is it possible to look like that without some sort of enhancement?
He doesn't believe it is.
He doesn't think it's physiologically possible for a woman to be built like that
and less somewhere along the lunch has been taken some shit.
Like if you look at those really fit crossfit girls,
those really in shape women,
they look fucking tremendous.
But they look like women,
you know,
they have good arms and they have,
they're thick and they have like big legs and everything like that,
but they have a much more feminine look to their musculature.
You know,
there's a certain level that,
uh,
that some women have gotten.
And you know,
Cyborg.
One of them.
What's the joke used to do about the fucking,
the whole Noah's Ark was a retarded boy.
Oh boy,
look at a little bit on steroids and tell you something ain't right there.
Yeah.
Okay.
You could see it.
So there's,
you see the neck and the fucking jaw line and the,
I mean,
her upper body was,
I mean she had traps [inaudible] traps.
Can I go?
Okay.
So I mean,
I understand what a woman burns.
Fat titties gets lost and it's,
but it's harder for a woman to have a,
a muscle definition because they have an extra layer of fat and all that stuff.
But you could,
I'm no InQuicker phenologist and I could tell that bitch did something.
She did a lot more than to see it.
Uh,
uh,
what is it that GNC shake and a fucking weed.
A pill,
you know what I'm saying?
She did something,
well,
she could tooken this shit.
They used to be legal at GNC.
Like she could've gotten on some mag 10 or something like that.
Was that stuff strong?
Oh yeah.
It was ridiculous.
GNC,
maybe they banned it.
They used to have it.
I took it.
It's called Mag 10.
You took it easy word to the word.
If you were lifting weights,
you would notice if you like did it and took it and lifted weights lifted for
other reasons.
What otherwise is we?
I don't remember,
but maybe I did take it when I was working on,
I don't want it to be yoked now.
Remember when you got really doing anything to me off?
Yeah,
they got rid of it because it was like a steroid.
It's like taking a steroid and I'm not saying you could get big without juicing,
but she was at the point where you knew,
you knew something was going on.
Her face started looking like very masculine too.
And what's really crazy.
It was a video of her from her first fight ever.
And if you go back to her first fight ever,
she looked like a woman.
She was built very differently.
If you look at it like she's,
she looks,
she's still bad ass.
She's still going to war with some checks.
She's thrown down,
she's a shoot box fighter,
but she looks like a woman.
Her body looks like a woman.
It's kind of shocking the difference cause she looks,
she's scary now.
She looks like she would fuck with me.
She come back.
I don't know.
She might not ever come back.
Who knows?
You know?
I Dunno.
Yeah.
She'll come back.
She's got to go after running around.
Yeah,
but I mean they have to,
once she comes back then she has to have a hearing to try to get her license
back.
You know?
It's not as simple as you come back once you come back.
He's due to you.
Once you do the suspension,
you're good.
I don't know if that's necessarily the truth.
I'm not sure if to stall subpoenaed at ACA.
I think you have to get licensed because I think that like Chell son and when
they had a fight,
Anderson Silva,
he had to get licensed in Nevada and that was a part of the thing.
It wasn't just a chill son and had been that he had been a band for x amount of
months.
He also had to get licensed.
So I don't know.
I don't know the whole process I think,
I think,
you know,
there should be consent.
There's a difference between a woman doing performance enhancing drugs and a man
doing them.
In my opinion,
when a woman starts in introducing things that just don't exist in that level
ever in our body,
you know,
it's different thing to that.
Then a guy taking like testosterone replacement therapy to try to be like a
young man again.
It's really kind of tricky.
It's uh,
it's,
it's almost like you're a,
if you,
you can't go down that slippery path cause they're like we talked about like the
weight cutting thing.
If everybody has to wait,
cut man,
man,
that kind of fucks things up.
It would be better if everybody didn't have to rake weight cut.
It'd be nice if that was the reality.
Well if women start taking male hormones,
that is a mess.
That ruins the whole idea of the woman's sport.
You know,
if you,
if you have women taking male hormones,
there's a,
that's not women fighting anymore.
That's a hybrid.
That's a woman man hybrid.
Women with male hormones,
like you're fucking the whole tree of life up there.
Like this isn't just you trying to reclaim lost youth.
You're creating
a thing that's not quite a woman anymore.
That's what that is.
You're,
you're adding some shit to a woman that doesn't belong there.
And I think that has to be taken very seriously.
That's
so sad.
It's so sad.
And that's what they have to do,
right?
Because that's what that sport demands because the look,
it's all about body dysmorphia at that point.
When you're involved in bodybuilding,
it's just like when you see a woman,
and no disrespect to anybody who has this,
you know,
your tits are too big and you're crazy.
You know,
like you just get like a thousand CC's and they're like,
I want to get another 200 like,
what are you doing?
Stop it.
Like,
have you ever seen those videos on these people that can't stop getting bigger
and bigger?
10 implants.
They're crazy.
That's,
that's how bodybuilders are.
And they get this body dysmorphia and they just,
it's not about looking good.
Like if you go back to like the Frank Zane days,
you know you go back to like before steroids,
you know,
that guy was in tremendous shape and he was proportioned and it was all about
making your body working hard to get your body in proportion.
Then it became about steroids and then the Arnold Schwarzenegger error and then
forward,
you know,
into the,
like the Lee Haney era.
It became about these cartoonish,
monstrous human beings.
It became straight Tom Platz.
It became strained body dysmorphia.
As soon as they figured out how to add drugs into the equation,
everything got completely wacky and women started getting wacky to which one was
Frank Zane.
This is,
there's a woman who lived down the street from me and I won't say her name,
but she was a very successful female bodybuilder back in the day and now she
looks,
she looks like she's paid a price for it.
Man,
it's sad when he sees her.
She has a lot of masculine characteristics that she shouldn't have.
She looks like,
like she fucking hijacked or system.
Like,
she just,
she morphed herself,
you know,
she marked herself and turned herself into a man.
Basically.
It's fucking crazy,
man.
It's crazy.
Like she's wears makeups,
tries to be womeny but you like,
you know what she used to look like and what she did to herself.
She turned herself into some sort of a masculine creation.
And even when they get off this stuff,
they still maintain some,
some masculine features.
It's really strange.
You know,
they uh,
their body grows.
Shepparton gets big,
you know,
it's,
um,
it's a very unfortunate thing that someone decided that that looks good for
women.
They taken some crazy shit that makes you closer to a man because a fit woman
is,
it's beautiful to look at a fit woman and to not accept that a fit woman is
going to look different than a fit man.
It's craziness of fit woman.
A woman who was in great shape.
It works out.
Like I said,
those crossfit girls that sexy as fuck,
man,
let's got girls.
I've incredible bodies,
but they look like a girl.
They look like a woman who's in great shape.
You've got to Noho cc the chicken Nigos which cross train like my God,
she's got a body that don't fucking,
well,
Rhonda Rousey doesn't like the fact that her arms real big.
Like when she came on the podcast like,
oh,
everyone's going to see 'em all yoked.
You know,
I kind of want to cover my cover,
my sleep.
We were like,
what are you talking about?
Her body sensational.
It's sensational.
Oh,
but great girl.
But she's,
but she is so strong that to a guy who doesn't exercise or diet doesn't work
out.
Like Brian,
she's very intimidating.
She was fucking him.
She wouldn't ever let him be on top.
Like how are you going to get on top of Ronda Rousey?
You're not okay.
Well she's gonna,
she's gonna fuck you.
Fuck you forget.
She weighs one 45 well one 35 now,
which find it.
I bet you she's ticklish.
I find take their spot and no matter was just stop talking.
She'll wake you at great legs to do whatever she wants you.
I was like,
God,
yeah,
she's got an incredible body,
sexy side.
But that's a woman's body.
You know what I'm saying?
There's no doubt about it.
That's a woman's body.
It's not.
It's an,
there's nothing creepy about that.
The only time it gets creepy is when you do creepy shit.
When you do creepy shit,
that's when your body starts looking creepy.
There's just no way around that man.
You can't take male hormones and the be still,
it's like a sexy woman.
Like that's just weird.
But they,
the dude's in that bodybuilding world that liked those types of checks and they
get into that man.
They like it.
Uh,
she's a freak.
My girls are free.
You got to see your quads,
honey.
Show me your quads and they give this fucking spray tan the leg.
It's like black as coal and flex their dirty painted toes.
And you'll see some strike patients in that thought and they're like,
what are you doing?
Why is that there?
Why do you have this?
Why is there no fat on your leg?
What can I see all the fucking ligaments in the muscle fibers under there?
Cause like I always looked at them,
that little push to get trolled tiny flat
chizen you go to suck a tit and it's hard right away.
You gotta be fucking tripping.
Cause when they strike Jewson they get the same thing in here is guys gift for
doing like close grip bench presses and all that.
This starts to get little fucking things inside their chest that's discussing it
and also they have little titties.
I looked at them like I've been through one of those contexts years ago.
My buddy can beat it.
So I went and I was watching these chicks are going to look at those,
you know,
look at dead bodies but at least even it could just save the Monkey.
Could you save the monkey cause all that.
Well they grow clits Bro.
Hooky strengths up the cleats,
everything Shreesh the click grows.
Joey,
have you ever seen all the girls like a dick dude,
it grows like a deck.
Yes.
Chicks badge off and she got one of those tight little habits.
I'm fucking out of that.
I'm telling you it grows like a dick.
Yeah,
I've seen it online.
I've never seen it in real life.
You've never seen it?
No,
no.
In real life.
I've never had,
I dated this one girl who was a bodybuilder when I was like 20,
and she was,
uh,
she was from New Hampshire.
It's pitch was loked out.
I was 21 because I was doing comedy.
She was a fucking was the first girl,
first girl ever about that,
but I never seen I die Bro.
This girl wasn't like that.
She was natural.
There was,
this was 1988,
whatever it was.
I don't think too many checks.
We're doing it that way.
But uh,
she was,
uh,
she was just so fucking down.
This girl's crazy.
We had sex.
She was on her period and she sucked the
blood off my deck.
That's how crazy.
This bitch was.
Good girl.
I was like,
yeah,
but you're on your period.
She just looked at me and starts sucking and I was like,
Whoa,
God,
that's a rare girl.
My fucking faith.
That's a rare girl.
Like lick the clots and everything off your Dick Nick.
The big black blood clots.
There was no black blood clots.
Unfortunately it was just a lot of red,
but she didn't give a fuck dude.
You know what?
She just starts sucking it down.
When you fuck a girl in the muffler,
you put it in the fucking mouth.
You know who first invented that?
My happy.
She's my girlfriend or my sad like am I sad?
But I just stuff it up a fucking ass.
Whatever's good.
You should be happy.
Did you want to do that?
Did it feel good that she get off on it then you should both be happy.
Only if she's clean.
It's not that disgusting.
She got to wash it all out though.
It's got to go to work.
I've heard.
Can't just casually watch your asshole and have shit.
Aga Addictions.
Shit has never happened to me cause I fucked and faint.
I wake up and beat the girl merciful to me for having a dirty ass.
It's a scared me like that.
I would fucking like the time in Seattle and I put the bottle in the girl's
pussy and we put up work at all in the grill.
Why was that the same chicken?
I found the aluminum foil harass that saved chicken were in Seattle and that was
tricky.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
Gallo brothers wine.
Cool.
And I started rubbing the bottom and I'm a little bulky.
She was a stripper.
And then I pulled a little thing and I started working the fucking bottle.
It's like a little monkey that's dangerous.
That has killed the girl fucking story.
Fatty Arbuckle fucking work on this bottle is a little monkey,
right?
And I'm down there about to lick the fucking click.
And next thing you know here,
the suction of the bottle at suck the period Outta oh round vampire blood from
blade shattered was
a little darker.
It was just disgusting,
Bro.
I fainted because I,
my mind,
I caught her with a bottle.
I was like,
no.
I'm like,
I cut real.
I've went down.
She had a walk.
God fucking animal.
She didn't give a fuck.
About a month earlier,
I pulled the fucking little aluminum foil out of her ass.
That was the same girl,
chicken Seattle.
That was good.
That was a year and a half.
A fucking great freaky stories.
Tell me things that you stick in a girl.
Well,
you know,
she was a fucking savage only live once.
If you're dating a savage and you really like aren't,
you're not in love with her.
You try to do shit to her until she breaks up with you.
Right.
It is amazing how much people very unlike like that girl that would suck the
blood off your deck.
Wow,
that's so variable.
You know like the real freakiness like when you meet someone,
what they're down for,
what they're not,
you know,
like,
yeah,
you ever date a girl,
you just,
you just start dating and she jerked you off on her tongue while she's looking
you in the eye and you're like,
Whoa,
what?
We just started hanging out and you're you,
you're opening with this.
Like,
God damn,
where the fuck is this gone?
You turned me onto something.
I almost called you at four in the morning and called Your Cock sucker 20 times
because it was one of the most devastating things that I've seen in
my life and I'm not being funny right now.
And how you sick motherfuckers watch that shit is beyond me.
I finally watched that Sasha Grey video that you referred to me when the 20 guys
are fucking up and she's got a dick in her ass.
And but the funny thing about the via is extras and the video and they're just
standing around and jerking off with that dicks waiting.
And I'm sitting there going,
Joe Rogan is a fucking lunatic for making me watch this shit.
Sasha Gray looks like they beat her.
Like she sucked and fucked 20 guys like you sweat.
And that's all wet.
Like it looks like she was in a work after they were punching her.
She's a fascinating chick cause she's a very smart,
no,
no.
It's interesting though.
I've ever heard of be interviewed.
I've read some of her interviews and she's deaf.
Deverie definitely very smart.
But so is Dana d Armand,
you know,
she's smart too,
which is weird.
Just Day to know Danny.
Dear mom,
the girl that's on our podcast before,
she's done a lot of crazy shit too.
And she's been on a pump.
She's a nice girl.
That was on the other night.
The other night she was saying she put things that are asked and everything.
She's crazy.
I read,
retweeted one of her lines one time.
It said,
uh,
someone asked me what is the craziest thing that's ever been in my ass?
Answer cat toys,
which I had cat toys and Oreos.
Me More cat toys.
She's crazy.
But she's fun.
She's look all I give a fuck all I give a fuck.
All your Nice Dude,
what?
I meet you or you're a nice person and you're nice dude.
Can we get along?
And I meet her.
She's always friendly.
You know,
I'm judge,
she's nice.
She's nice to be around.
I bet she's very nice,
but I'm gonna be worried about it.
Yeah,
be worried.
I'm always worried psychologically.
And when I see someone do one of those crazy movies where you know there's 15 to
as you're choking off in your eyeballs,
you know,
it's like,
what is that like dog?
She had it and I was on,
I was really disturbed.
Like,
I'm like,
this is crazy that people are telling me I'm dirty on stage.
You got to see this shit this and people want,
there's a market for that.
Like I didn't an that people pulling their hair and they're fucking putting shit
in her mouth.
I was crying.
I almost started fucking crying.
I felt that fucking emotional.
Wait until you have a daughter and then you watch it.
Yeah,
I watched that.
Did you watch that with your daughter?
And I'm sensing watch it with your toe.
You know what I mean?
I'm saying think about the fact that you have a daughter in that your daughter
could grow up to be that girl.
I the way I was the only time,
but here's the other problem.
She likes it.
She says she likes it.
I don't,
I don't want it.
But if,
uh,
you,
you had to,
you know,
tell me,
hey,
somebody offered a Sam Tripoli a movie and he's a,
he's got to do it and he gets to fuck a 15 hot girls.
Sam Aaa would do that in my mind is it's bad for Sam trebly if he's lying there
in 15 girls are shoving her pussy and his face.
Is that bad?
No,
it's not bad.
So why is it bad that she fucks 20 dudes?
Well,
it's only bad really,
because in our mind it's bad,
but you shouldn't,
shouldn't like that.
But she says she likes.
How much would they pay?
Like Sasha grey.
Like any idea of a bunch of grant more than anybody.
He's friends with all those choices these days.
They're not,
I dunno.
Nowadays they're not getting,
they're not getting that much money.
Like Sasha Grey for fucking 16 now.
I know a girl that just did her first 60 bucks for that.
I know a girl hit her first anal,
her first anal.
I know this girl and she's like a pretty new up and coming up in comedy.
But you think like,
you know for your calmer,
you think you would have,
she would get a lot of money for her first time,
but it was like $1,000 Oh,
how fun.
Is that up and comer?
Well,
she's an up and comer.
Yeah,
she's fucking,
she's got to scale the great heights.
Oh,
it's come with it you though.
Yeah,
but I'm saying the idea of like where are you going to go?
Bucks to get fucked in the ass.
This is what I'm saying,
but this is like,
oh,
a lot more than that.
What if it's good?
No bonuses.
Yeah.
White people fucking pay for your hair and makeup.
You pay for your fake Tan.
You pay.
Really?
Yeah.
You get it figured out.
You paid for,
you're an AIDS test,
butthole cleaning you.
You gotta do it yourself too.
Yeah.
What is it called
now you've got to take an animal to you.
Gotta clean out your bottle.
Here's what I don't get is how guys are s there's still guy porn stars because
you know that,
that that has to be like zero money guy porn stars.
They must be paying them a couple of hundred bucks.
At least for a lot of guys,
man.
Like I know dudes would done porn and there was like,
you know,
I didn't want to work at fucking Mcdonald's so I could,
I could do this and I can make 500 bucks.
Like,
there's just some desperate people out there and they fucked some girls on film.
You know,
Tyler,
our friend Tyler night we had on the show,
fucking great guy.
Normal regular dude.
And he's out of the business.
Dot.
I think he's writing books,
writing books,
and he's got an actual real job job.
He was like,
what your corporate.
But he didn't.
Yeah,
he probably has to hide.
They make money.
I mean,
do you make money?
Um,
you know,
I think you make enough to pay your bills.
You know,
you can get by if you,
if you're live cautiously and you'd do a lot of fucking,
I don't think you're getting the ranch unless you're like a famous guy.
You call me and go,
joy,
you busy as happened.
No,
not really.
What's up?
Listen,
the way to come on.
Will you fuck this chicken?
Come on up phase.
I'll give you 500 bucks.
That's not bad.
I'm gonna fucking come on somebody's face.
But to get fucked in the ass for $1,000,
that's just wrong.
I would want at least 10 gs.
15 gs.
Well,
the whole world changed.
You know,
the whole world of porn completely changed weight.
When they stop selling DVDs.
DVD sales disappeared when the internet came along,
they just disappeared.
They dried up completely.
Remember when laws are,
WIC was saying the sky is falling because they had figured out a way to download
things off the internet.
That was back when people weren't even that good at it.
Napster file sharing and shit like that.
Now it's just the fucking game is over.
The game's over.
So there's no more money in porn DVDs anymore.
It's probably,
I bet it,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't be surprised if it diminished by 95% people will write those.
They used to,
but now nobody rents something.
Now they can,
they can sell them I guess to direct TV and cable where you can buy videos to
go.
Cause then if you've flipped through those late night channels,
it's like
10 bucks a movie or something like that,
or $9 a movie.
And they,
they're always there.
They always have video.
So someone's buying content.
So I'm guessing they're selling something to someone somewhere,
but it's nothing like the roaring twenties of porn that they had that they
experienced out here for a couple decades,
for a couple of decades.
It was like,
even though it was not respectable,
there was people that have these giant ass fucking houses and drove Ferrari's
and the neighbors would be like,
well,
who's that guy always in porn?
He's in porn.
But it was like he was so rich,
he didn't candidate the scumbag was living next door to you,
but this guy was like a porn guy and he would drive front and Ferrari and he was
making millions and they would laugh at all these people that weren't in the
porn business.
Listen,
we make it you,
you buy it,
okay,
I sell it.
You pretend you don't buy it,
but you do buy.
And that's what my house is.
So big baby.
Well that guy doesn't exist anymore.
That guy doesn't exist now.
It's like these hustler dudes who are like sticking a camera and a girl's
asshole and you know,
and,
and filming these audition tapes where girls could meet them in,
in conference rooms and they fuck them on a couch and come in their face and
make them sign a waiver.
And it's all like,
you know,
like Gonzo style.
Like that's like,
what's,
that's like what's big and porn now.
And it's like the,
the,
the movies that they used to try to make these try to make like porn movie.
He had d'evelyn.
Mrs. Jones was a porn movie,
you know,
behind the green door with Marilyn Chambers.
That was a porn movie.
Deep throat was a porn movie.
People went to see it like there's a video of a photo rather of Johnny Carson
waiting in line to go see deep throat.
Deep throat was a pornographic movies.
The chick was sucking Dicks,
but it was still was a movie and it was an artistic movie.
You know,
that shit doesn't exist anymore.
That there's no,
that was back then when you,
if you made porn,
it was like you're the only,
you have the only copy of it to sort of get to,
so for someone to get it,
they have to get it from you.
When you made deep throat,
there's only one way to get deep throat.
You've got to get it from the guy who made it.
Is it going to make more copies of it?
How do I get it?
It didn't even exist.
It wasn't even a VHS tapes though.
You couldn't even see something again whenever you want it to.
That's why when I saw star wars when I was a little kid,
there was,
the thing was you'd go see star wars like 10 times.
I saw star wars,
I think it was like 10 or 13 times or something crazy like that.
That's what everybody did.
You know why?
Because you couldn't get a DVD.
There was no DVDs.
There was no vehicle was gone.
It was over.
Now we're in the exact opposite.
Now I'm sitting here talking to you and all I have to do is go,
oh yeah.
Well let me go to iTunes real quick.
What the Godfather Dick Order and I'm getting it.
And then while you're talking,
I press play and I'm watching the godfather that quickly.
I mean it's ridiculous.
The saturation.
Did you go to New York?
Uh,
I started calming an 88 and I met,
saw spin,
I think it was 90 I met Sosman 89 or 90 was deployed still big in New York.
42nd street.
Yeah.
Which they hadn't cleaned it up yet.
Yeah,
it was,
it was scary.
It was a,
it was a dangerous world back then.
It was a different world.
The eighties,
42nd street was,
was dirty man.
It was like you didn't go down there and it was,
it was like,
there was like porn theaters and it was,
it was,
it was hustlers and hookers and,
yeah,
and they have those weird signs and the signs would like say like what dirty
movies plan.
It would be right there as you're driving by,
there was a lot of them peep shows.
And you know,
and my friend Johnny used to go to peep shows when he was on crack.
He said that smoking crack,
he goes,
you could never get a,
you could never get a hot on but you're always horny.
So I'd go and he's fucking dirty pitches.
They'd be right behind a glass and I pay him and they'd be,
they'd be right in front of me with a dirty ass and I'd be checking off and I
couldn't get a hot on and he goes,
but I'd be there all day when I was smoking crack.
When he some that somehow or another like the people that are smoking crack,
like they get on those heavy amphetamines,
smoking,
those things.
They want to,
they want to watch a lot of porn.
That's like a big thing from like math people.
Like a lot of math people like to watch porn.
I guess it's cause it's just,
they just want to go super dirty.
What height?
There's just clarity.
You want to get your Dick sucked.
You know,
like,
I didn't know like porn,
but when I lived in Aspen,
boulder and I would pick up chicks like they were like porn and I'd say get it.
You know,
I'm not going to watch,
I'm just going to snort coke and fucking get my dick sucked.
When you get,
when you get cocaine,
evil,
cocaine,
evil is horrible because that's how you get your hips moving a chair.
Like as she's talking to you,
talking about sucking your Dick,
Joe Rogan,
your hips start to move the way I like my things will be gyrate and you're just
looking at a porno.
You know,
I've seen girls at gyrate event chairs while they're coked up
like fucking like a savage,
like just get all fucking,
I like all that shit as far as,
let me tell you something.
I would make a chicken for the chicks did something,
Michael,
she was sucking my Dick.
Dick got hard.
You understand me?
You know you get freaky.
You think it's things you want to do,
but you can't because you've got dead Dick.
But why are you so freaky though?
If you're just,
I don't know.
You just want it.
It's like,
hey,
these experiences too.
You want what?
You can't get you what you what?
What happened?
He goes,
I know you had a common thing for a while.
What'd you,
what'd you get into?
You get hard ons when you,
oh,
I never had a problem.
Not Getting hard on ever with any drug or anything.
I think I find it very hard to believe.
I think once when I was sick,
like I tried to masturbate when I had like a temperature,
really high temperature and I couldn't do it once.
When you're six you couldn't get it up.
What do you consider it up is you're up.
Like if I get black eyes draw,
I have a harder dick then if I didn't have a drunk.
Okay,
next time you get black out drunk,
I want to take a picture of your deck.
I'm going to get it hard.
You defy the laws of physiology.
That doesn't even make sense.
I don't know.
I seriously like I can call it,
everybody has a problem.
Not only can I have the biggest hard on when I'm drunk.
I also last like stupid and long amounts of time,
like an hour and a half.
That's normal.
That's because you don't feel as much that that happens with me too,
but I think that's normal when you're drunk.
You know,
we're like,
get off dot.
Good.
But never had not been even such a difference,
man.
People don't smoke.
We don't even know her fucking feels like when you get high with your,
and
you know you just,
especially if you really love a check,
you'd been there a while,
you,
you're like really close.
You're not fighting.
There's no bullshit.
There's no animosity,
no weirdness,
no need,
no extra need.
That's a hovering over every fucking conversation you have.
It's a lot bad relationships out there,
Joey Diaz,
but if you've got a good one,
if you got a good one,
you smoke weed.
But the lady and my Gout,
I have some sex.
I'll tell you,
it's a credible,
it's a,
it feels 20 times better.
Yeah.
It's like no bullshit.
When you get high and you just hanging out with a chick,
it's so much fucking better.
He wasn't drinking.
Yeah,
always fucked up for me.
They got that fucking wine breath is shit.
The fly guy.
I like the light that'll like alcohol.
Like it.
I like,
I like whiskey breath cause you know why that's a chick that's going to make
some fucking mistakes and we're going to do something crazy.
He could talk her into some shit.
I grew up in a ball like I like it if you can keep it together.
I like a good drunk.
I don't mind the drunk.
I was like a drunk.
They can keep it together.
Hanging out with a drunk tonight you're going to hang out with the drink
Chrysler.
I love bird.
I love that guy.
Might drink tonight cause I haven't drank in a week.
He came on the podcast yesterday and I was just thinking what a fucking positive
guy.
You know,
when we were talking about this whole desk squad thing about all of us,
one of the most beautiful things is the friends that we've made and that we've
formulated this group of really nice people.
We can trust all of them.
You know,
like Bert Kreischer.
I trust that guy.
I love birds.
I trust him to,
to like always be nice.
I trust him to always,
I always want to hug him.
He's always great to talk to.
He's a good human being.
You know?
There's so many good human being,
Brian Collins,
same way.
That's,
he's a great human being.
I fucking love Brian Count.
You know what I'm saying?
Give we five.
Dot Brand.
We've made our brand,
we formulated our brand and what's that from?
We've made our brand last Friday.
Yeah.
What was that from?
That was good with that kid.
Oh,
who was the show?
Oh yeah.
That guy was fucking beaten our ear and talking nonsense.
Fucking showbiz terms to us.
We got trapped.
We've got trapped in a weird conversation between you guys really have
established your brand.
You know,
I think you guys done an amazing job of establishing your brand and I'm like,
you are speaking.
It's crazy
because I wish,
I wish that everybody at one time got to see New York City in the 80s just to
see that.
Just to see that.
Let me tell you something.
I used to go to those peep shows as a the kill term.
I worked on 52nd street and I'm going to,
when you're 13 you go to get to see a piece of pussy.
It was the Raunchy was first of all where they hired a guy to go in there with
the mops cause you walk out and he's right in there with a mop and that mob
picks up that load of sperm.
You come on the floor.
There's no tissues in those places.
You know,
when I was a kid,
I fond in a really big karate tournament.
Madison Square Garden.
I run banks isn't all that.
It was a big karate tournament.
I was like maybe 16 I was still in high school.
Walk over.
I don't remember.
I don't remember much man.
I remember there's a lot of fights aren't definitely got tagged in it had a few
times.
So my memory of the weekend.
You didn't go with the peep shows?
No,
no,
I didn't do any of that back then when I was a,
I didn't even believe in pleasure back then.
I thought that if I needed pleasure,
I was weak when I was 16 anymore until I got my first girlfriend.
Then we start fucking like Robinson.
Totally.
It was totally right.
Distracted the shit out of me for a little while.
But I didn't,
I tried to avoid sex.
I wouldn't even fuck my girlfriend in the school cause you know,
I used to teach at my martial arts school,
so I was gone.
I was in high school and I had keys to this fucking building in downtown La,
Boston rather.
Not even downtown Boston,
but this is building in Boston.
I would teach there.
I mean I would go there and I also,
I would also like to go there because I had a,
I had my car back then.
I would like to go there and work out.
When I knew that everybody was asleep,
I had this crazy thing where I want it to work out.
When I knew that everybody that I was finding was asleep,
that's when I would go there like two o'clock,
three o'clock in the morning.
I would start my workouts and uh,
I was dating this freak bitch and she would go with me.
She wanted to fuck all the time.
She was dirty and she was so dirty.
She was,
I dated one,
I did it a few really dirty girls when I was young,
but this one was just down,
down DTF all day.
She was just crazy.
It's amazing when you first start fucking when you're like 15 and 16 that's why
I go,
I always loved that song.
Night moves,
that Bob Seger Song because that reminded me of this check because me and this
chick were just awkward and we were in love with each other supposedly.
But now really what it really was like,
we would just go on these horrendous fuck Rampage's to try to escape our reality
through a relationship,
through intense sex.
And you know,
just the awkwardness of growing up.
But that night moves song,
I live a pussy made me get loved back in the sixth grade.
Then
they would tell you about the six grade we and what does this experience?
12,
right in the sixth grade.
How old is that?
I was in love with this girl in New York,
no reason.
12.
She was a skinny little fucking Cuban chick and a follow up downstairs.
The mother was hot and every afternoon when she would say to me,
cause I,
you know,
I don't know why she'd go listen like a date yet,
but we can't date though.
School ends.
That's what my mom's is I a day boy.
So we had to do it and I hung out with her brother.
I brother would beat in like each other and I reacted and I bring over to my
house.
I put on earth one of the fire,
can't hide love off the fucking,
uh,
the live album and we dry hump over and over to that song.
I would suck a little funnel to these.
And finally they had those little funnel to these in the sixth grade.
The best was my mother hated when she would be in the room,
like my mother would come home and go,
what the fuck is she doing here?
We'll open the respect me and I'm going to come on.
Yeah.
What was the open numb room shit.
And one day my mother paid one of the guys from the bar to go over there and get
a ladder.
My mother and her,
I'm,
I'm dry humping the girl and I'm hearing this shit in my backyard,
but I'm like,
I'm going to give a fuck.
I'm trying on this bench drunk and I'm talking like I'm in this bitch dog,
dog,
dog.
And all of a sudden I hear,
ah,
my mother paid the guy like 50 bucks to get a ladder and tele what we were doing
in there.
But the latter,
it felt,
yeah,
take it to the hospital.
He broke like a finger,
broke the phone off the ladders.
No Pussy Bro.
But the first time like it was like she told me I couldn't kiss her.
Like we couldn't make out of shit tool.
But this is crazy because we weren't going to make out to the day after school,
but she was gonna let me lick a little pussy and I remember the first time I
smelled this pussy I was like in the sixth grade I fucking just went numb.
It was like my ears,
you know before Michael Quality only shoots shoots a lot.
So how the train but it's really his deafness from your,
your your,
I didn't know Joe Rogan.
My head was hot and it would just lick my hand.
Did it smell like this?
Your face gets all red number.
The first time you fuck face would get red day and I'm going eat up pussy and I
was done dog don.
I didn't eat a pussy every fucking day.
And that's what you did every day I talk her into coming over.
Do you think that started your worldwide post lifelong obsession with pussy?
Pussy?
Nah,
there's one girl.
It sounds like it is.
It sounds like it's a positive.
I won't
stop.
I was in the sixth grade,
I was in the sixth grade and then what happened was we got caught playing hooky,
so it was like a endless love by parents told us we couldn't hang out with each
other no more.
It was fucking crazy.
I was going to burn the house down and everything and then I got sent to summer
school because I wouldn't do homework.
Right.
That's all I would think about.
She would eat her til six I would go home and eat dinner and then we'd get on
the phone till two in the morning.
You know,
it was fucking Donny and Marie type shit.
You know?
I didn't know.
Our parents didn't let us hang out and I got thrown.
I was supposed to get to summer school at eight 30 so in fact I had to go over
there instead to eat her pussy because by that time she let me stick it in there
a little bit fingers and I would go fingers and like,
well no.
Well she's touching your Dick at all.
No,
I didn't know I was such a Catholic little fag prude.
Then really want to touch him.
My Dick,
my Dick.
I didn't want her in my life.
Did you get boners I got boaters.
I got big dicks.
I wanted to fuck.
But yeah,
those days and when I was from the aid Lewis,
I got to tell you some guys from the age of 12 to about 17 if a girl grabbed my
dick,
I told her get dressed and leave real.
I was one of those fucking mobiles,
like I didn't want blow jobs.
Like I was looking for a wife.
Really?
I'm looking for a woman.
I don't want to check.
That sucks my Dick,
that bitch,
she's a whore.
And then first time I got my dick sucked,
bonafide.
My Buddy Louie Denato,
I still remember him.
He's like,
dog,
I got this massage place.
You got to come up and help me do security.
Like I made team dog.
I'm like,
oh,
how much are you going to pay me?
He's like,
I can't pay them,
but I have to check.
Suck your Dick.
So I just wanted a blow job,
so I didn't tell him the truth.
I went up there with that.
I'll do security dog.
I stood there like one of the chicks and the suck your Dick.
He goes whenever you want.
So it's chick took me in the back.
She had low,
I never forget that she sucked my Dick.
Then she goes,
you could cut my hair dog.
I left there fucking mummified.
He's like,
he's like,
go ahead.
You got to work the door for a few hours.
Went home.
It took like three showers and a Hottie I commit a crime.
Like Bro,
when I was a young guy,
I was a prude.
I was very prudish.
Did come in there.
Oh yeah,
I'm not that much of a fruit was somebody lets you come the hand and it's their
idea.
What the fuck.
You know I'm coming again.
But I didn't like it.
Like I said to him,
I really didn't like that stuff.
I don't know why.
I don't even know why.
It was really weird.
I was uh,
I was approved to a fucking a long time dog then I didn't give a fuck what you
probably saw vice,
he saw so much vice as a kid.
You saw so many things that you would like,
I'm going to avoid all these problems.
I'm going to avoid all this shit that I see around me.
I see chaos,
I see death,
I see loss.
I'm going to avoid all this vice.
That's the only thing that makes sense.
If you didn't want a girl touching your Dick,
you obviously rejecting the fucking suck.
And it was my,
I was the captain,
but then I was a captain.
He didn't want them to touch your dick at all,
but he didn't do anything to them.
Like what are you worried about doing something?
Like what?
What were you worried about?
Like what was it about that they were dirty.
If they touch my,
like if a woman grabbed your dick,
she was dirty.
She was crazy.
You know how like people would all smoke pot and look at people smoke pot.
They see a hallucination.
They see the devil.
That's what I,
I've had some conversations with really rational people.
No,
so I've had that.
We tell him you smoke pot and they blow a fuse.
Like they don't know how to talk to you anymore.
You see like the hiccup in their system,
what smoke pot
grow years later,
bro,
me and that girl became really good friends,
that girl that we would dry humping and she's right.
You know,
and uh,
I think like two years later we became good friends.
We were fucking backyard buddies.
You know,
we had,
we shared a backyard and I had a friend of mine who stole bicycles and he would
always put them together and go,
hey,
come in,
drive this for a couple of days,
let me know what you think.
And you drive.
And they come back and go,
you know,
steering wheels fucked up.
You got to tighten or whatever.
He was a mechanic so he took,
gave me this tense Pete,
when he goes,
bro taken taken,
let me know what your fixed.
So I take it,
I'm playing and we was a bunch of kids.
I was in the seventh grade cause I got left back.
She was now in the eighth grade.
I was the eighth grade and she was a freshman.
That's what it was.
And we were all playing on the same block and uh,
she took the bike.
Somebody said,
go to the store.
She threw the pack and I go,
where's the bag?
And they sit in New York.
It took it,
she's going to the store.
This was a block that was circular.
What do you call those blocks?
Culta sacs called the sex.
And the middle has like an island.
Yes.
So I was on one side of the street playing to win football and she was riding a
bike this way.
So me and my friends started running at her bro.
The steering is loose,
but she thought we were going to fucking chase her.
Right?
Like we were chasing and take the bike away from.
I'm like,
no,
I'll take the bike.
But the student was loose,
don't make a turn.
But she's giggling,
Bro.
The fuck.
And she went to make the turn.
She flew over,
it landed,
we got up,
she went home.
The next day I walked to school and they're like,
come in for a second.
Remember your girlfriend?
She's in critical condition.
She landed on her head and got a blood clot in the middle of five note.
Ah,
she had a shave her head.
Let me tell you how good looking this girl was.
She still won homecoming queen with the ball fucking handle.
So what'd they do?
They have to open our open the skull.
And the weird thing was that she was always flat chest and after I bumped her
head,
her kids got gigantic.
I bumped to the head,
made her tick,
but it was really bad because our families were mad at each other.
And I remember one day her brother was like a dick.
He didn't like me and him and his father came home.
My house like to talk to me,
but my stepfather was in the yard.
That's the first time I seen him pull a gun on somebody in Jersey.
Like I never seen him pull a gun on somebody in Jersey.
That's the time he went out there and he goes,
check with that 45 these motherfuckers got back and they called back and they
turned around cause they knew my dad had a reputation but not jersey.
He was like nine jerseys.
His house,
he didn't want any problems.
He would hide his guns in his yard so they wouldn't be in his house.
We were out there mowed the lawn and also we've seen the white corvette bro.
And I go dad,
that's the guy.
New Yorker reasons.
Father.
My Dad looked at me,
even hesitate.
He just went right over.
He lived a Martin Scorsese movie.
Dude,
that was fucking crazy.
It would be a good Martin Scorsese movie to Martin.
Get on it.
By the way,
by at Joey Diaz.
Holla at me calculate cause tonight motherfucker tonight it's almost sold out
the ice house in Pasadena.
It is going to be a God damn spectacular extravaganza of a show.
We got Randy Lipkey is hosting this bitch.
We got Tom Rhodes all up in this motherfucker.
We got Dom Arrera Holla at your boy.
We got Sam Tripoli,
we got Brian Red band.
Who else?
Doug Benson Benson's all up in this chamber.
Chrysler Kreischer nab up deck.
They don't want to draw that.
Bird's got a car.
Burke takes a fucking car service so he can just throw down and me.
So we're all up there tonight.
Yeah.
That's like an insane lineup.
A tremendous lineup for 15 bucks or 15 bucks.
And we got three fucking shows.
And by the way,
we do it all the time and it's fun as fuck.
And we love it.
We love doing shows there in Pasadena.
And when Joey and I have a big show this weekend in Denver at the paramount
theater,
these shows get us fired up for it.
This is like a,
this is how you tune in.
And he's like,
two,
not last week was fucking incredible,
man.
It was fucking so was the Improv man.
The improv was fucking incredible.
That Friday night was amazing and Amy Schumer was great too.
She was awesome.
Blow fucking that.
I couldn't get them till the end.
They didn't like me in the beginning.
Really.
They weren't our regular people really.
That clubs kind of uncomfortable for me.
I always do.
That's so cool.
You know what it is?
You,
uh,
you,
you start off first.
So going up first is always harder.
Going up first is a weird thing.
You gotta gotta get them in the groove.
They're not asked me.
I went up there to fight.
He was sick and he was sick.
Then I will get too fast and try to be thinking about the last set you had
there.
Oh No.
I have my news because of that club and because of my last set there.
I have it.
10 minutes of clean material now.
Well that's good.
Yeah.
You should always have just tools.
You can just whip out there that in the back.
It's not even just,
there's still no you,
you like,
your comedy is so weird and if someone knows you then it makes sense.
But it's like there's so many comics that that's the case.
Like when someone like,
not that you're Mitch Hedberg,
Mitch Hedberg used to bomb all the fucking time.
If people didn't know him,
then once they knew him then people would come to see it.
You know?
But you're a fucking Weirdo dude.
And people don't know why you're throwing calm on the wall and a hotel room like
the fuck is this idiot doing.
It doesn't even make sense.
You know,
you're a grown man.
You're not 12 years old and you know,
like saying some cutesy Shit,
you're almost 40 and you're talking about throwing loads like Spiderman on the
wall and people are like,
what the fuck are you doing?
You know what I'm saying?
So until they know you from the podcast,
that's a tough pill to swallow,
son.
Once they know you,
they're like,
oh,
silly red fan.
Oh,
silly.
And also tonight we have the icehouse chronicles that goes off about tenish.
We usually do it about a half an hour before the podcast and if you want to tune
into that,
it's going to be right here on this motherfucker right here on this Ustream
channel,
bitches or Brian.
You got to rename these all these to say Joe Rogan live.
I thought you were going to go back and rename me.
So that would take forever.
Yeah,
well got to do that,
dude.
You got to do that,
right?
I can't just have Joe Rogan live and not know these is used stream.
A lot of people do these Vimeo or youtube,
they use this too.
Yeah,
I know what I'm saying,
but do you know,
they may not know why the amount of people that rewatch it on Ustream instead of
youtube or Vimeo is like 1.0007% that's not true.
Not only,
not only is that not true,
you don't know.
And there's a lot of people that take clips off of these things.
It's hard for them to find what the,
what the um,
no,
it's not off youtube.
It's all,
it's also when you stream,
a lot of them have a lot of use,
man.
A lot of these have a lot of views.
I know.
And it happens before it goes up on Vimeo.
Once it's on Vimeo,
that the amount of people,
once it's on Vimeo and Youtube,
like 0.0,
that's all good.
But it's still has thousands of views.
Yeah,
because it happens before.
But Brian,
that's happening right now.
Still need to be labeled.
They need to be late.
We talked about this before.
You can't just not label them.
That's just crazy.
What?
What should happen is,
is when I label it at the end of every podcast,
you should save the label,
but for some reason it doesn't it.
Yeah,
there is a glitch,
but we still have to label them anywhere.
Fuck,
go together Cox.
So just watching the history.
Soccer's no,
Brian,
you got to,
this is the youth stream to say,
just wash to use Vimeo.
You fucked up pal.
If there's any reason to watch a on Ustream,
there's,
there's no reason to watch it on Ustream Maynard's on Bryant.
If they want to watch on Ustream,
they should be able to watch on Ustream.
We just didn't needs on Ustream,
which just it needs to be labeled anywhere.
It is.
It needs to be labeled.
You can't just have watch it and find out who the guest is.
That's silly.
We need to label it.
Okay.
I think everybody on Twitter would agree and I think majority of people probably
watching it on youtube or Vimeo.
No,
they're watching it right now on Ustream and they might go back to it and watch
it again.
Thousands of people do.
This is a silly conversation,
Brian.
I asked you to do it and you didn't do it.
It's all it is now.
You told me to start doing it.
I've been doing,
I said we have to go back and relabeled them too,
and that's,
that's insane.
How many,
how long that will take.
Oh my God.
That's a job,
Brian.
That's what part of having a job.
Don't forget to come to the ice house.
Me,
you're not even doing those videos anymore.
We're not even doing it.
Told me to stop recording so we have time to give you more time to give you more
time for shit,
for going back and labeling to give you more time to do other shit.
They need to do a hired somebody to do that.
She'll pay him 20 bucks to do good.
Well,
she would do on a tremendous show.
Make sure you go for the no,
this is a silly conversation,
right?
A lot of people who have to do things in their job,
they don't know.
What I'm saying is if you go to Joe rogan.net where everyone goes to watch in an
overbearing,
I know your point,
I know your point.
But the bottom line is it's on the Internet on Ustream.
There's the channel where people watch the show live when they want to watch
your life and none of those things are labeled right.
But what I'm saying is if you're going,
hey,
I want to watch Joe Rogan and Joey Diaz right now,
uh,
I'm gonna go to jail.
Oregon's website.
Oh,
there it is.
cool.
Okay.
No one's going to be like,
go,
what's he going to do?
St TV backslash Joe Rogan.
Yes,
they would because that's where they watch it live.
You don't think they bookmark that?
They watch it live all the time.
I see.
I know,
I know.
It sucks and I know I'll have somebody do it,
but I'm just saying it's really ridiculous to watch it on like an inferior,
like the version on Vimeo.
Beautiful.
The version on Youtube.
Both of those are,
you know,
easily on your phones,
on your DVD players or new TVs.
Like totally understand.
They still watch it.
I told her son that however it is there,
and people do watch it,
so it needs to be labeled.
There's one guy somewhere in Iowa,
so a lot of people do.
There's thousands of views on all of these videos that you're watching it right
now,
that maybe and a little bit in the future,
but they need to know what they're watching.
It's not that big a deal,
man.
You're not working in Malaysia.
I know.
Fucking farming Jakks Rachel does talk to this kid.
Tell him,
straighten them out it.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't know what's going on.
All I know is tomorrow night,
Friday night,
paramount theater,
eight o'clock,
Brendan Walsh,
Joe Rogan to taking it off the fucking hoax.
Joey Diaz ready or rock stolen to the gills and then with the Mandalay Bay
events center,
the whole fucking dead squad crew,
the flying jewel,
Duncan Trussell,
Joey Diaz,
everybody man.
The fucking headline of Joe Rogan.
Where else we go to the Mandalay bay.
One's going to be big.
The Mandalay Bay one is,
we're doing the Wayans ladies and gentlemen,
where the wins are for the UFC.
It seats like think it's like 3000 people.
That's what we're doing.
We're doing,
when they block it off for the wins,
that's the area we're going to do comedy yet.
And there was the idea of Mandalay bay because we used to do that theater that
they had.
Um,
what was,
what was the show that things like the lion king and they,
uh,
they changed that.
They're doing a new Michael Jackson type thing and they're building it up right
now.
So that thing is closed.
So it was their idea to do that.
So this is the first time we're ever doing this.
We're going to do the Mandalay Bay theater and that's August 31st and again,
that's Ari Shaffir,
Joe Diaz,
Duncan Trussell inmate.
So it's going to be fun.
It's fun.
Next Wednesday you were in Nashville,
Chattanooga,
fucking Atlanta.
Fucking Michigan,
Mississippi.
I tell you what,
I'm coming to Nashville xannies Wednesday eight o'clock six one five two six
nine oh two to one gets you a fucking tickets now.
There's a couple of them left.
We need to do a paper view.
Joey Diaz,
uh,
storytelling shows those shows that you're doing.
That's a good idea.
Put that shit up,
but then shut up.
Well,
you know what it was like number 29 for the on tools.
How many of those have you done so far?
I got five of them.
The one that we just tape.
I got a problem with the one before.
It wasn't that good.
So we scrapped it and their audios and the audios yet I'm putting them up on
iTunes.
This is a fucking great,
that's beautiful.
Right?
Testicle task 99.
What do I give a fuck?
Yeah.
Beautiful.
Beautiful people to get this.
This one's good.
It's a kidnapping story.
So the first one,
I hate you hard.
I don't fuck around it.
Okay,
Ladies and gentlemen.
So it is a,
it's 10 to seven right now on the west coast and uh,
at,
uh,
10 o'clock.
So three hours from now we will have the icehouse chronicles and you can watch
it live on this.
USTREAM.
Chan on the,
Brian thinks that nobody goes to watch it.
Like a TV four slash jogging for life.
I know.
I'm fucking around dude.
Really?
I love you guys.
Relax.
We love,
we love all you guys.
Thank you very much for all the,
the positive Twitter messages and all the positive Facebook messages.
You guys are cool as fuck.
I,
yeah,
I made a commitment to start using Facebook again.
I'm gonna write like longer blog posts and shit and just put them up there.
Um,
you guys are the shit.
We have the coolest crowds in the world to come to these shows and don't think
we don't appreciate it because we talk about it all the time.
Brian talks about it all the time.
I do,
we got on the phone after shows.
Sometimes we can't believe it.
We're the,
we're the luckiest people alive and rock the world.
And we,
uh,
we appreciate you guys and we support you guys,
100%.
The reason why we're doing this,
it's because we love to do it and we love it because you guys love it.
It's,
it's all feeds itself and it all marches on the beautiful life that we live.
Use The mind,
ladies and gentlemen,
fines big.
Why?
Find the direct path.
I love you,
Joey.
Coco.
Thanks to [inaudible] dot com go to o,
n n I t.
Use the code name Brogan.
Save yourself off 10% save yourself off 10% off a Alpha brain.
Shroom tech sport,
Trintech commune,
shroom,
tech sport is this shit.
If you work out hard,
take it son.
It's about quarter Zips,
mushrooms,
and beat 12 take a beat 12 supplement if you're vegan.
Otherwise,
what do to bring strength.
Anyway,
that's it set for this week.
We'll see you guys soon.
We love you guys next week.
We've got a whole lot of people.
I'm not sure if dice clay still doing it,
but uh,
I believe Jamie Kilstein is coming in.
We've got a lot of Shit happen in folks.
We'll see you soon.
We'd love you guys.
Thank you.
Okay.